the first bill for our public hearing
this morning hb 1163
and
this is relative to over voted ballots
and with us is the prime sponsor
representative porter welcome
representative porter representative
porter has another committee to get to
so we thank you for your time thank you
madam chair and members of the committee
for the record my name is marjorie
porter i represent hillsborough district
one the towns of antrim windsor and
historic hillsborough
which is celebrating its 250th
anniversary this year
i come before you this morning to
introduce hb 1163 relative to overvoted
ballots
last year
on which you did not look favorably
but it died on the table
and since then we've had the audit of
the 2020 wyndham election results to
show how important the provisions of
this bill are to fair elections
if the provisions of these bills had
been in place in 2020
what happened in wyndham where shadows
created by the foals in the ballots
caused the machines to count them as
overvotes
would not have been possible
i'm hoping you will look more favorably
on the bill this year
and i have some visual aids here because
i am a teacher
an overvote happens when more than one
allowable number of votes have been made
for an office or a ballot question
so if you can see this
this voter
has filled in both ovals
neither santa or oscar the grouch gets a
vote for this
okay
when a voter fills in her ballot like
this
in communities with vote counting
machines
and in communities where hand counting
occurs this voter's choice will not be
but let me show you some other ways that
and see if you can tell me if you can
determine the voter's intent
with that ballot
i thought this was stiffer paper
okay
santa
here's another version
two filled in ovals
one x out initialed and the one that
stray marks are on the second oval
but it's clear when you look at this who
won that vote
this ballot was folded
and there's a shadow
coming through
the oval
but it's obvious
currently voters with these types of
marked ballots in towns where hand
counting occurs
will have their votes counted because
the voters intent is clear
but under our current system
voters in towns where machines count the
votes would lose their vote because the
machines record as over votes all these
kinds of marked ballots
this creates two classes of voters
the good news is our machines can be
programmed to reject overvoted ballots
returning them to the voter much like
that change machine returns the crinkle
dollar bill
to you at the laundromat
this is exactly what happens in vermont
massachusetts rhode island connecticut
and many many other states maybe 49 of
them because section 301 of the hava act
of 2005
requires the voter be notified of the
overvote be informed of the consequences
and be given an opportunity to correct
it
including completing a new ballot if
need be
in fact when we were researching how
other states handle overvotes we often
were met with the surprise you don't do
that in new hampshire it's the law
i have given you a document describing
how other states handle overvotes
hb 1193
as original
outlines a process we would like to see
happen in new hampshire
but we have heard concerns both from
these committee from committee members
in this committee and from the secretary
of state's office about parts of it and
so we have also drafted an amendment
which we believe addresses those
concerns
and i believe that the amendment would
be accepted or be acceptable to the
secretary of state's office
i've given you copies of the amendment
in both versions election day voter
privacy is projected as only the voter
looks at or handles the ballot
in the amendment election day voters and
absentee voters are treated in the same
manner with no opportunity to fix errors
and with the overvoted ballots from both
placed in an auxiliary compartment to be
counted at the end of the day
there are others behind me who will
offer more reasons to vote in favor of
this bill or the amendment either in its
original form or as amendment
what i want to leave you with
is this
in the 2020 election in the town of
derry the machines were programmed to
record the number of overvotes
overall
4.7
of ballots
counted
were counted as overvotes
one machine used solely was used solely
to count absentee ballots
no other ballots
on that machine
14.2 percent
of the ballots counted
570 of them
had overvotes
570 people who voted absentee lost their
votes
leading me to believe the shadow issue
found in windham may have been more
widespread than we know
we have very close elections in new
hampshire
they can be won or lost by a few votes
so every vote should count
i hope you will support us in this
effort and i'll be glad to take
seriously
thank you representative thank you madam
chair thank you representative take my
question um you you just cited absentee
ballots yes dairy um however i i just
don't see the procedure for how we would
notify an absentee voter
that their ballot had overvote in the
same way that we would be able to notify
someone in person right because by the
time we realize it's an overvote we no
longer know who that ballot is from and
that's why we amended that language out
in the amendment
so the scenario you mentioned well
wouldn't it be if if if the amended bill
passes
all those absentee ballots will go into
an auxiliary to be counted and the
in-person voter will have their ballot
returned and the election official will
say please put it in this auxiliary bin
to be counted
later be encountered later so both kinds
of ballots will be hand counted at the
end of the day in the same way and the
election day voter will not be given the
opportunity to correct it we think that
weakens it somewhat but if it will if
making these changes will allow this
process to proceed in new hampshire as
it does in all the other states i think
it's we're willing to compromise on that
issue appreciate the answer thank you
okay thank you representative alexander
thank you madam chair thank you
representative um so my question is this
is just regarding electronic ballot
accounting devices and not hand
counted towns
um
why
so
why aren't we extending this to hand
counting towns
in
so
why are we letting
electronic ballot counting towns have
this opportunity but hand counting towns
not because in hand counting towns
the intent of the voter is clear when
they're counting the votes the problem
comes that the machine
miscounts
this as an overvote but if this ballot
came into a hand counting town
the
ballot counters would know santa won
this vote it wouldn't be oscar
okay follow up
thank you um so
what if the voter had an overvote in a
hand counting town
and that ballot wasn't
obviously was not like spit back out at
them
but it would it was it would be given
that opportunity to correct it in like a
machine counting town
i don't believe they would in a hand
counted town it would be noticed right
away because people would put their
ballot in the machine okay the only time
it would be noticed in a hand counting
town is when they're actually counting
the ballots at the end of the day
what happens the machines can be
programmed to count over votes and to
return over voted ballots and by the way
there's no extra charge for doing that
it's already done
the company that
does our machines does this for other
states so
the problem comes when the voter goes
into a
machine-counted town with an overvoted
ballot now the machine just takes it
but if this bill passed
that machine would spit it back out and
then it would go in an auxiliary to be
counted
so okay representative growing thank you
madam chair thank you representative for
taking my question
um
if
a voter
actually overvotes
not not
an accidental mark or a fold or any of
that but it's it's an actual overvote
yeah um
if
the original version of the bill then
would require that
ballot to be passed back to the voter to
be correct is that correct
to give the voter the opportunity to
correct it and if you look at the sheet
that i gave you
with the email messages about how other
states handle this it talks about what
their voter manuals tell the election
officials to do when an overvoted ballot
is spit out
okay and follow-up questions
uh
then following up on representative
alexander's question
in the case of of the original version
of the bill yeah
a machine counted town a voter who
actually over voted
would be given an opportunity to correct
but a voter in a hand-counted town would
not be given an opportunity and that's
why we amended the bill so in that case
the amended version is better than the
original
in a sense be in a sense because both
sets are treated in the same way right
okay this the amended version still
doesn't put us in compliance with the
federal law
but
it does allow
overvoted ballots to be looked at by a
set of eyes
and a decision made by the set of eyes
rather than the machine thank you
representative
representative o'brien
thank you thank you
madam chairman and thank you
representative porter for coming uh
would that be a privacy concern for the
hand counted towns to have a set of eyes
on that when the voter is there because
members of the
um
the town would know how the person voted
no no because in a hand-counted town the
person takes their ballot and puts it in
the ballot box no one looks at their
ballot until the end of the day and then
all the ballots are looked at and
counted so you're not going to know if
you're next to me how i voted because
i'm taking my ballot and putting it in a
hand counting ballot box
that's what happens in a hand counted
town
but in a machine town the voter puts the
ballot into the machine no one looks at
it and the machine would spit it back
out to the voter no one looks at it and
then the voter would put it in the box
no one looking at it until the end of
the day
representative
barry
um
this is what you get when you say nobody
asked me questions just fyi
i'm actually glad that you're asking the
questions because it's not an easy thing
to get your head around um okay i have
two questions about i'm sure i will ask
for my follow-up so just to understand
the amendment because i don't support
the underlying bill because it creates
two classes of voters but the amendment
removes that problem yeah um so now i'm
talking speaking to the amendment yes so
a person with an overcast about in a
machine countdown puts the ballot in and
it spits it back out yes and then the
person standing there takes that ballot
and puts it in a box or goes to the
diverter no the machine can be
programmed to say over voted ballot so
the person puts it in
it spits back out the election worker
looks at the
machine and says to the voter
you have an overvote on that ballot
please put it in the auxiliary box to be
hand counted later so nobody but the
voter handles that ballot until the end
of the day when the ballots are all
counted right follow-up so this uh hey
that's better than what i was
envisioning um but it's still underlying
problem is still there so now the
voter's been told they have an
over voted ballot
it isn't that but they don't have the
opportunity to correct it
isn't that going to create a
a
i would say dispute with the election
worker it might it might
that's why the language was in the
original bill
okay but that's
problematic language to many people
so it's been eliminated
it you know the rules that the secretary
of state sets up
for
processing these kinds of things can say
just tell
the voter that there's an um the machine
doesn't like your ballot put it in the
other the other box to have it counted
so if that that could be done and that's
a way to get around
fisticuffs
at the election site
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair representative porter were you
aware that state law currently allows a
voter to
get a new ballot up to three times
right yes
i am aware that i don't think
voters are aware of that
and that was one of the reasons why in
the original bill
we brought up the fact that the voter
could be told that he could get another
ballot if need be
but that created problems for
the secretary of state's office and for
many of these committee members
here so it was
but yeah there's an education process
that goes on that should be going on and
maybe
i don't know notification on
town websites and things like that might
help people to know that but maybe we
can put another sign up
if you've been one of the election
worker who does those posters it's hard
to imagine but we could do another one
representative prudhomme o'brien thank
you um i have kids
and i sometimes
have to make crazy signs around my house
to remind them to do things that i think
that should be self-explanatory
and
you can imagine i'm a teacher yeah so
you've been there yeah
i aren't the ballots posted with the
amount of openings in a field
so it would say vote for three when
there are three yes openings but there
may be five candidates isn't that at the
top of every it is
list it is okay
so i i'm not saying that all the voters
read all the directions carefully
okay they and and you know what comes in
as a confusing
in my district in hillsborough we were
are currently represented in two house
districts a floatario and a base
district
and so and we can vote for two
candidates in each one of those
districts and when you look at that
ballot if you're not familiar with that
it's very confusing
because it says state representative
vote for no more than two and then below
it it says state representative vote for
no more than two so here you've got four
you am i supposed to vote for four am i
supposed to only vote for two so people
who are not
um familiar with how things work and
there are a lot of people like that um
often don't vote for the right number of
people because it's confusing
representative muirhead
thank you madam chair
would you say that as things are now in
the absence of this bill being passed
that there are two classes of voters
with respect to overvoted ballots i
would say so because the voters in the
hand-counted towns get their votes
counted at least looked at by a pair of
eyes but voters in machine counted towns
do not so voters in machine countertown
could lose their vote
and those
people being voted for could lose that
vote as well i mean 570
over voted ballots in the town of derry
that's a lot of votes
you know that's a lot of votes to lose
in just one machine
oh i thought you did representative
mcdonald
thank you madam chairman good morning
representative porter thank you good
morning
um
i have my uh my question is do we know
if the um
the ballot machines will be able to make
this determination immediately or if
it'll take several seconds to
it does it right away just like when you
put that dollar bill in
something's wrong it spits it back out
the machine's programmed to do the same
thing so you put the ballot in it might
accept it and the minute it sees an
overvote it comes back out
and there's no charge to anybody for
programming the machines that way we've
checked
follow-up yeah
the reason i bring that up obviously we
want to expedite the voting process as
smoothly as possible especially in the
heavy turnout election and that would be
a great concern potentially thank you
and i believe that the ballot machines
spit out ballots for other reasons
besides um
overvotes
i think i've seen people's ballots come
out and they have to feed him in a
couple of times because there's a glitch
okay so it's not unusual
it is supposed to be right there yes
have i forgotten my question
um
my question is this if the machine is
going to spit it back out right
why does
why do i not have the opportunity at
that time to say or the person who's
next to the machine say to me
nothing like your ballot perhaps you
should take the right player and then my
vote would be
corrected and put in we can have three
ballots yes it seems to me i would get
my vote more accurately and maybe i
could get a little education as well
as what my problem was exactly
representative and that's why the
original bill was written the way it was
the problem is some people consider that
creating
two classes of voters because voters in
hand counted towns
would not have that opportunity nobody
would know it was an overvoted ballot
until the time of counting at the end of
the day so those voters would not have a
chance to fix it
thank you i understand okay
thank you representative quailey thank
you madam chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
as a selectman i had the opportunity to
observe the mechanical function of
functioning of a voting machine
for many hours
and it was not uncommon
in our town at least for
a voter's ballot to be rejected upon the
first attempt
to submit it right
and it might take two even three tries i
suppose depending on initial alignment
or whatever
is there
uh and you're understanding a way for
the election worker to distinguish
distinguish between a ballot that's been
rejected for an overvote and a ballot
that's just simply been rejected because
of
that kind of momentary difficulty yes my
understanding is the ballot counting
machines can be programmed so that when
an overvote is detected it says so right
on the screen at the top of the machine
so the bat the election worker could
look at the machine and it would after
the ballot came out and it would say
further questions
representative prudhomme o'brien thank
you ma'am uh
i hope that i see our the dairytown
clerk here and i'm not sure he's going
to speak on this but
for that reason i'm going to ask you and
if you don't have the answer that's okay
are you aware of the interesting special
unusual dynamics that happened in the
dairy election because
we as candidates did anticipate that
there would be many overvotes but prior
to the election
i i am not familiar with the details
prior to the election actually i'm not
even gonna that question is you need to
rephrase that before you re-ask that
question of anybody because i'm not
going to allow that that was way too
leading
or whatever okay
what
anybody else for representative porter
that gives you time to rethink it
all right thank you very much
representative porter thank you
committee members and
have a good day i'm going to go down and
fight battles in education now
see this wasn't a battle though so there
you go all right next signed up to speak
thank you madam chairman members of the
committee i'm here in support of this
bill
to require the
val counting machines to be programmed
to return
over voted ballots
um
i find that
the important part of this bill is
actually in the sentence
the last sentence of part 1 which starts
on line 10 in the middle it says balance
of ab t voters and those who choose to
correct or replace the ballot
and choose not to correct or replace the
ballot shall be placed in the auxiliary
compartment and counted
i see by this requirement that
um every
ballot that has a
absent has an overvote
will
be uh
segregated out and put into the
auxiliary compartment
and therefore every machine shall report
zero overvotes
it doesn't fix problems with undervotes
but it does
eliminate overvotes on the machines and
i see this as being
actually the most important part of the
bill
change it so that the
in-person voter doesn't have the
opportunity
to
correct the ballot
but
this is actually more important than the
few in-person voters who may over vote
or have stray marks on their ballot
because it eliminates the overvote
potential from the machines themselves
and i even think it's
we have to consider that it's more
important than whether or not we have
two
classes of voters or even four classes
because we have voters in towns that
don't have to deal with machines and
know that their votes are going to be
looked at by hand county
as well as we have absentee voters
who get to vote from the comforter
living room or dining room or whatever
and don't have to drive anywhere in the
rain or snow or whatever to go vote
uh with that i urge that uh ought to
pass on this bill
i did want to
make one other comment on this
that last sentence in part one
um
i see that as a possibility that first
phrase says balance of absentee voters
and those and continues um
it almost suggests that every
absentee ballot has to be hand counted
um
so that sentence might be rephrased to
say and and this is in my written
testimony that you have and and also the
what i sent online
ballots of absentee voters returned for
an overvote and ballots of those who
choose not to correct or replace
the overvoted ballot shall be placed in
the auxiliary compartment and hand
that may need to be changed slightly if
you adopt the amendment proposed by
representative porter
and i thank you and i will answer any
questions if there are any
seeing none thank you very much
and we have i do have your written
testimony for the record here
and it has been submitted electronically
good morning
thank you for the opportunity to speak
on this bill
this is a very important bill
in my mind
i live in the town of windham
and i'm sure you all know the issues
that took place during the election
that were discovered after the audit of
and this i believe will address many of
the issues that were discovered
um but before i begin i'd just like to
suggest that this
election integrity bill
and it is for election integrity it's a
nonpartisan issue and that can be
reflected in the fact that you have
sponsors from both parties
that have signed on to this bill and i'm
grateful to all of those
uh reps and for doing so
i want to point out a couple of
um
things
that are related not just to windham but
to other towns as well
during the general election in 2020
you heard that derry had 4.7 percent
of their
ballots had overvotes on them
merrimack
one of their machines tabulated a
massive number of 396 overvotes on
1738 ballots that's a
22.78 percent
uh
percentage
of ballots that had overvotes on it and
i am hard to believe that
nearly 23 out of 100 people
who put their ballots into that one
machine actually made that type of
mistake
on another machine in merrimack
there was only 14 overvotes out of
1856 ballots for a 0.75 so less than one
percent of the ballots so from 23
percent of the ballots in one machine
less than one percent in another machine
this is the statistics don't make sense
manchester
had a machine that had 14.99 percent and
another machine that had 2.37 percent
windham had um
292 overvotes on one machine and 18 on
another
so 8.9 percent versus 1.3 percent
hampton
had the same type of situation 9.51 on
one machine 1.65 on another
and those anomalies can be seen across
the state
i've actually looked at the paper tapes
of all the towns across the state
and this is not just isolated to win him
it's it's an important issue because as
you heard in previous testimony
the machines can misread the ballots as
you've also seen in the
in the forensic auditor's report the
machines did actually misread ballots
when they were put through the machines
and when that happens
and it triggers an overvote those the
voters votes for that race are
disenfranchised
and it's it's not hundreds it's
thousands across the state it's many
many thousands across the state
cumulatively and that's
that's really not acceptable if we want
to make sure that our elections are
accurate and this is a very very very
simple
the there were some questions i
appreciate all the questions that you
asked and i appreciate the answers that
rep porter gave
in response to those
you know it's my understanding uh with
talking with the secretary of state
that
um that
when the ballots go in
and they get rejected they they get read
as as an overvote it come out
you know in my conversations with him
and and in my experiences in the windham
voting in windham when the ballot
doesn't get taken
you're instructed go ahead try it again
try it again and you're right
it does take two or three times
sometimes
but after that in my conversations with
secretary scanlon you know if it rejects
it two or three times then the election
official
can
instruct the voter to take the ballot
and put it in the auxiliary compartment
nobody's going to see that ballot but
the voter
and the
and in this process
the
the election official doesn't even need
to lean over and look at the machine
right because it's it's not really
changing anything
the only thing that changes if it
rejects it two or three times is now
there's an alternative let's put it in
the auxiliary compartment and the
benefit of that is is that these
machines are not going to falsely
tabulate overvotes and then
disenfranchise the voters
and and again as we see in the windham
election that's exactly what happened so
machines do make mistakes that's this is
not a theory it's been proven that that
actually happens
there was also concerns about
having two classes of voters well i
would suggest to you today that we
already have two classes of voters
that in the towns that hand count
ballots
those votes the intention of the voter
are actually being counted
and with the machines as you as you saw
with some of these examples
ballots could have
you know in the in the case of a race
for either a single you know wherever
there's more ovals filled in
than are allowed someone might exit off
and then initial it i actually saw that
multiple times
when i participated in the hand recount
for the windham
general election for the state rep race
and that was an education experience for
me because i i could see
that yes there are times where the
ballots actually would be
read as an overvote because of the way
that the voter filled in the ballot
but
in the recount
the intent was clearly known
and it was put off to the secretary of
state's office to decide that on
election night it's the election
officials who will decide that and i
think that that
is also part of election integrity
because you want the intent of the voter
to be honored at the end of the day
so
i believe that
with the process that's outlined in the
amendment
but if the ballot gets rejected
they get instructed to put it into the
auxiliary bin there are no two classes
of ballots anymore
the
uh secretary the secretary of state they
put together an election procedure
manual
they could clearly
define what the election official should
say to the voters if their ballots get
rejected multiple times
they don't have to tell them you have an
overvoted ballot they could just say
please you know it's the machine's not
taking it please put it in the overvoted
you know in the auxiliary compartment
and everybody everybody's ballots are
treated the same then
in the sense that if there are
you know red over votes by a machine
that will that will be eliminated now
going forward and again it's thousands
and thousands of votes
and as you heard in previous testimony a
lot of these racism in new hampshire are
decided by
by just a handful of votes and if i
remember from a previous bill that
senator guida wrote
44 out of the last 45 elections were
decided by one vote or they were tied
so it's really critical that
if
machines are going to be continue to be
used
that we try to eliminate
all of the potential errors that might
come up when we're using them
and i think that i've covered most of
what i wanted to do
what i wanted to say so i just thank you
for your time and please this is a very
important bill to pass please uh please
vote ought to pass it is nonpartisan it
is
election integrity and after
uh the last two years there's quite a
few people who are concerned about the
trusting our elections right now and
this would go
quite a ways to doing so
thank you mr eyring is does anyone have
any questions for mr erin
i'm not seeing any thank you for coming
this morning also signed up to speak on
thank you madam chair
for the record my name is mary till i'm
a former town moderator in derry
and ever since i served on this very
election law committee in the
legislature
i've made it my goal
to ensure that everyone who is eligible
to vote has the opportunity to vote and
to know that their vote has been
accurately counted
hb 1163 is one small step toward that
goal
part of the problem of being cleanup is
that most everybody has already said
what i was about to say so i'm going to
testimony very short basically saying
that i agree with everything that's been
said already
what 1163 does is ensure that the intent
of the voter is considered when counting
votes
the new hampshire supreme court
made it clear in 2003
that intent of the voter is the legal
standard
in new hampshire that's
2003.
in hand count towns the intent of voter
is noted and honored in machine count
towns the machine discounts votes as an
overvote
denying all candidates a vote in that
particular race
on that ballot
this is most egregious
in multi-seat races
like many new hampshire house seats
1163 requires a simple programming
change to return an overvoted ballot
directly to the person
in-person voter to be placed in the side
pocket it's free because
as was stated
lhs has written this program for our
neighboring states who have been using
it for years
so i'm basically going to say please
pass this legislation so hundreds of
thousands or thousands of new hampshire
voters will not be
discarded votes will not be discarded in
upcoming elections
let every vote be counted
it's time
and i
support the amendment that's been
proposed on at the request of the
secretary of state
thank you miss till
representative quailey
thank you madam chairman
and thank you for taking my question
it's my understanding that ballots with
a write-in vote
are automatically segregated into an
auxiliary compartment by the machine
uh if the same kind of action were taken
automatically by the machine for
a ballot that it detected an overvote on
would there be uh
how to put this a an onerous burden of
separating out the
write-in the ballots with right-in votes
from those that are judged to have
overvotes
so that both could be hand-counted at
the end of the
day
so excuse me
so it would not be onerous really to
separate them because you can see a
handwriting
person but the fact is it wouldn't even
happen because
one cannot tell
um
by quickly scanning
a ballot that there's an overvote on it
we don't know why that ballot ended up
in that pocket that's why we're asking
the voter to put it in a third pocket
that's called the auxiliary pocket
where
the entire ballot is recounted
in the
right in pocket we only have to recount
the write-ins
okay thank
seeing none thank you for coming
also signed up to speak on this bill is
and representative taurosian if you
could get me the clipboard at some point
that would be great this is the last
thank you madam chair members of the
committee i'm david scanlan secretary of
state
would be in opposition to the original
bill hb 1163 consistent with past
testimony
and i won't repeat that testimony
because you've heard it
many times in the past
but i will say that that the amendment
that has been
submitted by representative porter
amendment number 757h
is something that
the secretary of state's office could
get behind
it does not create a an additional class
voter but hold on deputy scanlan could
you give me that amendment number again
the amendment number that i'm looking at
is 757 h well then i think we have a
problem because that's not the amendment
seven four one h yeah
repre uh i'm just gonna allow a little
uh
changing committee process here mr
eyring do you know what the issue is
here
i do you know what amendment number
all right you want to approach deputy
scanlon very quickly because it looks
like he has both amendments and if you
can point out the difference please just
to him very quickly he's got them both
there i'm going to allow that to happen
because if it's one word that should
have taken a lot
quicker so
we're not going to go talking about
amendments we don't have and
we'll have to figure this out exact
session so
deputy
secretary scanlan thank you madam chair
the the amendments are essentially the
same there is some minor wording that
i'm going to take a closer uh look at
but
but the uh
it doesn't change the position that i
would have relative to this amendment
where
if a
a ballot was placed in the machine that
contained an overvote
that ballot was rejected
returned to the voter to be placed in an
auxiliary bin so that it could be hand
counted later
is something that we would support
i think that had
a system like that been in place
in windham given the issue that they had
with
the fault on the ballot
causing the machine to perceive an
overvote when one did not exist that
that
issue would have been uh
not completely taken care of but it
would not have been to the degree that
uh you know
that that actually occurred
i will say just just to address some
comments that were made earlier about
the current state of the law
and the fact that the federal
the federal harbour statute
does have a requirement in there where
machines reject overvotes
in in states
that there is also an exemption in that
same statute that applies to new
hampshire
that says that those states that have
paper-based systems that provide
instructions to voters on how to
properly mark their ballot
is exempt from that requirement and so
that is the exemption that new hampshire
has used all of these years i'm not
aware
of
how many other states may take advantage
of that same exemption but we certainly
do
in section two of the bill i would say
that that there's a
requirement in here that for each
contest or ballot question
the number of overvotes and undervotes
be recorded
i think it's a fairly easy thing to
record overvotes
it may not be as easy to to do
undervotes especially in hand count
towns so
you know i would suggest for the time
being that we drop
and undervotes on line 16
of the original bill
until we have an opportunity to
think more about how appropriate that
would be
and then i would like to just address
represent quality's question about
you know can write in votes and overvote
ballots be sent to the same
bin uh in the uh in the
under the accuvope machine
i i think that would be confusing
because in the case of write-in votes
the the the ballot is counted except for
the office or offices that contain the
write-in votes
and then when they're counted by hand
it's just those offices that have the
right in votes
that are counted whereas
if there's an overvote
that that's the reason for why a ballot
was rejected the entire ballot needs to
be counted and so i think for that
reason alone it would be best to keep
those ballots separate to eliminate the
confusion and the potential count hours
errors that might occur as a result of
that
with that i would be happy to try and
questions
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair
secretary scanlon a
question on the term undervotes i know
that the reports of the accuvope
machines use the word blanks is that the
same thing as under votes
um
i'm not completely sure i know i know a
blank would be if there was an office
that simply had no votes on it
um i'm not sure whether the whether the
machine would
consider a blank
a situation where it's vote for four and
the voter only uh marked three i'd wanna
research that and get back to you
representative bergeron you're referring
to the tape at the end of the night that
has the blank number
it says it uses the word blanks
doesn't say under votes i'm just
wondering what that word what that
accomplishes okay
representative
barry
so the machines have the diverter in
there for the write-ins that put them
into a separate spot and your concern
is that it counts everything but the
write-in
um
and then the
people at the end of the night have to
count that they just count that one
candidate right couldn't we reprogram
the machines to if there's a write-in
they don't count the ballot at all they
just put it in the diverter and then at
the end of the night and we do the same
thing for overvotes right it all goes
into the basically these the the ballots
that go into the bin the diverted bin
are just not not they're not counted but
don't want somebody to pull a weird clip
on the internet but they're not counted
by the machine they're counted entirely
every office by hand at the united
couldn't we do that and that would kind
of have our cake and eat it too
i i
i'm sure that the
software programming could
could occur that might accomplish that i
would have to see how
involved that would be it would require
an additional approval of the bow law
commission for
any software changes that would be made
that would allow the machine to do that
i would add though that some towns have
actually removed the diverter
excuse me from the machine because of
jamming issues that
you know have occurred in the past
especially when there are many folds
on the longer ballots it was uh
the diverter actually caused jams that
was frustrating to some
communities and so the diverters have
been removed and then
the
the moderator and the election officials
would go through all of the ballots
looking for write-in votes
afterwards so
the shorter answer is that what you
described could be done um but i think
we ought to give some thought to
uh
how that would occur
and uh just make sure we're as efficient
as possible
i have a couple in regards to
representative
the representative's question
um
is it fair to say that there are some
ballots particularly in local elections
that have races with no
candidate and that they are only
write-in candidates
ultimately
yes
okay so in that case when you had a race
that nobody had signed up before the
deadline but people were waging writing
campaigns it means all of those ballots
under that proposal would have to be
counted in their entirety correct
yes okay and when you talk about an
auxiliary i sort of felt like i should
when we're talking about a diverter
right now when it goes into the diverter
no one sees it right it's just going
most people don't even know such a thing
is occurring within the confines of the
plastic bin underneath the tabulator
so when you
when we're talking about an auxiliary
bin
we're talking about the voter actually
placing it in it but i'm assuming we're
talking about something more than a open
paper
box right i mean do you envision the
secretary of state
um
specific guidelines on what this
auxiliary container should be and given
what's happened in the last election
really really really specific guidelines
as to what the auxiliary
box should be
yes and my understanding is that there
is a third
auxiliary bin actually in the box under
the acuvo machine so
in the past if a ballot
uh is not read by the machine either the
corner is ripped right
that ballot gets rejected the moderator
takes it and puts it in a side auxiliary
slot right but we're already using the
axillary slots we're i mean i don't
how are we gonna we need another one
right well i don't know that we would
need another one because the ballot that
the moderator is currently putting in
that box needs to be counted in its
entirety and and so the same would be
true of an overvote ballot that's
rejected
going into the same
compartment all right then i have a
further question in regards to section
two which you spoke to nobody else had
spoken to
i had circled for each
election the number of overvoted ballots
so can the machines be programmed to not
only
say it's an overvoted ballot but to
count it and here's my question
and i believe the former secretary would
say maybe i purposely overvoted but
when i put it in it's going to reject it
i'm going to get told by the person
watching the machines to just put it in
again because sometimes it's just not at
the right angle it doesn't like at that
moment and maybe after two or three
times it's going to take it
at that point the tabulator has now
counted my ballot as a cash ballot
so when i put in
my overvoted ballot
and it's kicking it back out
how am i going to program that machine
to count that ballot as distinguished
from any other ballot because it's not
counting it when it's going in and being
rejected now it's doing the same thing
it i could do two overvotes and have the
next person put in a ballot that has two
over votes
and would the machine count that as one
ballot or
two ballots
and the reason i'm asking is
because of the question of tie outs and
legitimacy and i'm i'm worried about
an obvious mathematical problem that
will just create issues in regards to
the tabulation that's done after the
polls close yeah madam chair i i think
that i'm probably not the best person to
answer
that question you know it might be worth
getting
uh
somebody from lhs associates who
actually does the programming
to answer you know how that machine
might
uh you know
actually read the ballot that gets
rejected and my understanding is that if
it's an overvote
uh if it's programmed to reject an
overvote that the machine is just not
going to read that ballot
if if it gets spit back out but if it if
it goes through
it has probably recorded something
which is how you get a blank tally but
so my question is how do you get an
accurate overvote tally
that's essentially the basis of my
question if the tabulator is never
essentially turning on
to tabulate
how does it count again because you
could have successive
different
overvoted
ballots okay so
i'm gonna need an answer to that
question i think before if anybody's
listening and knows lhs and
representative
with the committee so yeah um let let's
get through
deputy scanlon we have one more speaker
and then
i'm going to let you follow up with it
representative terozian
thank you madam chair thank you
deputy speaker
secretary
scanlan taking the question
so i want to be sure i'm clear now on
how this works with a diverter so right
now
the way it's used if there's a
ballot that has a right in that goes
into that diverter box that's what goes
in there yes
uh does any other ballet go into that
diverter box currently
no the diverter would be to separate
ballots that have right in votes on them
follow up so if we were to adopt this
amendment then if i'm hearing correctly
um then the
overvoted ballots would then go in there
or no they'd still
kick out and be not counted
they would be they would be kicked out
not counted and then the ballot would be
placed in a separate auxiliary box
uh under the device so that the the
entire ballot could be counted
uh after the polls close
further questions from the committee
representative alexander um thank you
madam chair um my concern with this um
bill the original version without the
amendment is section two with the
um
for each contest or ballot question the
number overvotes and under votes um i
could conceivably see a reason
specifically in a primary or another
race where a voter might not want to
vote for the total number of people
they're allowed to vote for um you know
for instance in goffstown maybe i just
want to vote for madam chair and myself
and leave the other three blank so my
question is would the
are you advocating to remove
section 2 entirely from the bill because
it adds in the overvotes and undervotes
or how would you
how would you want that amended
no i would leave section 2 in i would
i don't have any questions oh i saw i'm
trying to be alert to red lights because
i'm missing hands
representative prudhomme o'brien thank
you thank you for answering these
questions um
i i found
yeah i'm glad that you addressed the uh
hava act issues
would this need to be approved by the
ballot law commission
after if it were
voted in favor of um because it would
require some
software changes is that true
the the statute would trump
the batlock commission
however
to the extent that software
changes would be required the ballot law
further questions for secretary scanlan
i'm seeing none thank you thank you
representative porter did you want to
come up and clarify because i know
you're in the middle of another
thank you madam chair um i appreciate
your concern um there seems to be an
issue with an amendment
the amendment that
um i presented is the amendment
the difference between the two
amendments the one that the secretary of
state just gave you and the one that i
gave you is that we had eliminated the
words election day
on line seven
and we decided i decided i didn't want
to do that so the second amendment that
the um is not the one we wanted we
wanted the one ending in 4-1
that one the committee has the one the
commit that i handed out to the
committee the second issue about can it
can the ballots
can the machines count over votes and
under votes
if they don't accept the ballot and
i'm not 100 sure on this but i have seen
um the
pages from the secretary of state's
office from the state of vermont who
uses the same machines we do and it's
programmed by the same people and they
show for each election
the number of overvotes and the number
of undervotes
so it is possible to get a count of the
overvotes
without counting the ballots because
they use a process where the
the voter is given a chance to fix it or
not
um and they use it the process that the
original bill set up
so they were able to uh to keep account
of overvotes and undervotes
further questions for representative
porter
thank you we'll let you go again
thank you
good morning members of the committee my
name is daniel healey i'm the derry town
clerk representing our town clerk
association
last year uh similar bill uh our
association opposed it um we're changing
our stance this year uh we're in support
of this bill
after
uh what took place in wyndham uh we
recognize that it won't uh cure all of
the issues with the folds in the various
things that
was found out
if you undervote and there's a fold the
machine it's not going to kick out
there's no overvote so it doesn't solve
everything but i think it's a step in
the right direction to to solve some of
the issues that were discovered
um
to the
to the issue that was just brought up i
believe if a ballot goes into a machine
and the machine it doesn't go fully
through the machine it's not going to
count on the tally tape so when it's put
in the side auxiliary pocket
the moderator and their staff at the end
of the night would take a tally of how
many ballots they pulled out of the
auxiliary pocket to to get your totals
for the
for the ballots through
i don't i don't believe unless if it
doesn't go through the machine i don't
think that that
it adds another ballot i don't think it
does another count for it right but you
understand if i have two successive
voters who have each
overvoted yeah
then the machine
i i've got i'm gonna i'm gonna have to
i contact
know how the machine would differentiate
that unless it was counting the ballot
to know that the votes on other races
were different
okay
from what i understand it doesn't count
anything until it determines all of the
races have either been over voted or
underwritten i see mary tell me maybe
you can catch me at the break ms till if
if you've got an answer to that
represent
representative growing
thank you madam chair and thank you mr
hilly for taking my question
do i understand correctly from what
you're saying is that
the machine would not count the
overvotes the overvote ballots would be
counted manually at the end of the night
so right now the machine would would
take the ballot and it um on our long
report it states the number of overvotes
at the very bottom of the tape right now
it would take the ballot and it it would
count it as a ballot cast i believe that
was turned on and so it kicked the
ballot out i don't believe that it would
then count it as a cast ballot if it's
with with that amendment i do have
i do like the amendment but i do have a
concern i mean i don't want to be
telling the voter oh just put it in the
side pocket when we know it's an
overvote and they're giving the ballot
back
and
we can see that it's an overvote and i
don't want to just say oh well there's
you know put it in the side pocket
because the machine's not counting it so
i do have a concern with that that we're
not really telling the voter all the
information that we know
that that their ballot um yeah but
theoretically you shouldn't have even
looked at that ballot to know well we
want to be looking at the ballot it
display which theoretically frankly
should be i've got an issue with how
close people stand to that machine
anyways so you're close enough to be
reading that you can see the ballot well
typically the moderator would be behind
the ballot box
well okay that's a discussion for
another day as to this bill and the
amendment because we are behind folks uh
representative prudhomme o'brien
would
you have to tell the voter
uh you have an overvote situation
and but at that same time you're not
able to tell them in what race there's
an overvote situation so
would they want to look at the ballot
with you how do you preserve the voter
privacy during this whole
situation that's my i believe that was
that that's the issue with the original
bill
is that then it's become less
confidential so the amendment that was
presented would then so you put the
ballot in the auxiliary pocket and
and the um the election workers would
i did want to mention uh something that
i heard earlier with the derry over
votes
we had a few residents come to us with
with that concern we had one very
popular undeclared voter so we had 21
candidates for state rep
choose 10 in three columns and i mean
there's no way for us to know this for
sure but
our assumption is that a lot of people
voted for 10
between
either 10 democrats 10 republicans and
they filled in that bubble for the one
very popular undeclared voter so i don't
believe that derry really had an issue a
huge issue with the
the overvotes in the election
representative quailey
yes thank you madam chairman thank you
for taking my question
uh you said your organization now favors
this legislation
as opposed to last year
do you favor the bill as
originally introduced do you or do you
favor it as amended or both or can you
explain to me any distinction you're
making
so i can't speak on the amendment for
our association um i can only speak to
the original bill that we're in favor of
um we believe that
something there needs to be some type of
change
because of what happened in windham
this would probably solve about 75
percent of of that issue
if the overvotes were turned on at the
time
okay thank you further questions
seeing none thank you mr healey thank
you that is our last speaker on hb 1163.
uh there were people that signed up
online i've been uh told that there were
161 in support 34 opposed and three
neutral
and we have one person who signed up on
the blue sheet who did not two people
who signed up on the blue sheet who did
not speak on this bill and they were in
favor i'm going to close the public
hearing on 11
63 we do have executive sessions
scheduled at 11 o'clock we will be
taking a 15-minute break between this
public hearing and the commencement of
executive session whenever
this public hearing ends
i'm going to open the hearing on cacr15
this is a bill that was previously
um
heard with the non-jermaine amendment
you have been provided a non-german
amendment
it has been provided to you it should be
in front of you and it is
0 7
h and this
is an amendment that establishes a voter
must be a citizen of the united states
and a citizen of new hampshire who is
domiciled
and whose primary place of residence is
in the state and he or she may only vote
in the place he or she is domiciled
copies of this amendment were available
at the sergeant of arms office and on
the general court
website and i have asked representative
berry to introduce the amendment to get
it on the floor so we can start the
public hearing on this thank you
representative berry thank you madam
chairman as madam chairman said i'm not
a sponsor of this amendment
but i am introducing it
as we said when we amended csr 15 the
first time the point of this amendment
is to begin to end the debate
over who is voting in new hampshire's
elections is it residents is it
domiciles is it citizens of the state so
this amendment attempts to address that
as i will be asking questions on the
amendment itself i will not be taking
questions
any further discussion thank you
representative barry
we have a couple of people
signed up on this amendment
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is michael o'brien
here on behalf of america votes i am a
lobbyist at pretty strategies
um here opposed to the bill uh first a
couple of reasons a few reasons really
but
for one on line 15
domiciled and life insists has primary
resonance a term that i do not believe
is defined within statute so we're sort
of putting words in the constitution
that have no meaning uh as to what they
actually mean um which is certainly
problematic um you already need to be a
citizen in the united states to vote um
citizenship is one of the things that is
asked for qualifications um so again i'm
not sure
uh the additional wording is necessary
there um also you need to be a resident
of the state to vote in new hampshire
right with the whole purpose of 1264 a
few years ago which was hotly debated
within these exact walls maybe there was
a wall in between but just about the
exact walls
was to equate the definition of
residency and domicile
and so again i feel like we're searching
for a solution to a problem here and
lastly i think there's a lot of
conversations in this room about making
sure people have faith in our election
systems and their processes and i agree
with that um but i do think also that
every time that we bring in a bill that
purports to solve a big problem with
people voting who aren't residents and
storming into our elections we are
pushing that narrative that people
should be afraid of our elections
uh when we all have seen the comments
from the governor from the previous
secretary of state the current secretary
of state many of you around this
committee have said
that we should have faith in our
elections that we should have trust in
our elections
if we were to push that message as
opposed to this one that we're pushing
through this bill people would have
faith in our elections it is up to us
and to you all as elected officials to
let people know
that they should have faith in the
elections um and to not create
narratives that would suggest otherwise
so that is my testimony i'm happy to
take any questions
thank you mr o'brien questions
representative growing thank you madam
chair and thank you mr o'brien um
you've mentioned um hb 1264 that helped
further define
residency domicile issues
um
i would assume you're aware
uh that
that has been a hotly debated issue for
many years many decades
and that definition has changed many
times i'm aware i've i've been in this
room for about 10 of them so uh i
understand yes sir and follow-up manager
you're also aware that this is not a
bill it's a cacr
i am aware to see acr um i don't think
the csr is necessary
okay and
follow up follow up please
um
since we have seen this issue argued
back and forth and changed back and
forth and back and forth would it not be
appropriate to
put in our constitution what we mean by
residency and domicile so that the
legislature can stop dealing with it
it's in the constitution primary
residence is not defined so it's an
undefined term so you're putting an
undefined term in the constitution which
i'm not sure helps anybody solve a
problem
but residents are the folks voting in
new hampshire elections
if people
again if we stopped saying otherwise
people would have faith in our elections
we have to stop reporting a narrative
representative barry um so i want to
talk about i want to ask you a question
about um
you say residency is not defined
but
sorry representing primary resonance is
not defined primary but isn't primary in
itself an adjective describing like it's
saying primary the the number one that's
that's literally a description
so i'm i i might defer to madam chair
here because she's a lawyer and i am not
but at private residence i believe is it
would be could be a separate term with
separate meeting and i think we'd have
to be very careful with that before we
put it i will just interject that as an
attorney i could carry things to no end
and there is a practice attorneys are
aware of when you ask questions that you
provide the definition
and there was once joking god that the
definition of thee
is because you can define
everything
so representative barry and in your
testimony you talked about you know once
again i'm going back to the definition
of residency here but we we do have
definitions of resonant in statute not
in the constitution but in statute um
and part of that is how long you've
lived in the state so
my question is is since this is dealing
with residency and residence is defined
in statute how long does your
organization believe you should have to
live in the state of new hampshire
before you can vote here
sure so um
i think the answer to that in my history
with america votes both as an employee
and now as as someone who represents
them here
um
the constitution is very clear both the
u.s and new hampshire once you move here
and becomes your home you are allowed to
vote here right so
if we started requiring could you before
you proceed could you please define home
sure so now we're going to go into the
definition of domicile which i think is
the place where you
you know where you spend where you
identify as your
civic engagement right so
um
it can be
i i would have to go back and i'm going
to get definitions to get myself in
trouble and i'd rather not do that
as much as possible though i seem to do
that more with more kids than i used to
um so
um but to say this that
if we were to start putting we've seen
bills in the legislature before about 30
days before someone can
um
you know can cast a ballot here
um you're going to start finding people
exclusions right so i move out before of
a state within 30 days of elections i
get here i can vote in federal elections
but i can't vote in state elections so
i've lost my voice in a state election
new hampshire is the place where you
live where you consider your home i'll
say that
where you have
an address that you would go to over and
over and over again
um
this is where you should vote and i
further questions representative barry
so i just want to follow up my previous
question because my previous question
was how long do you does your
organization believe you should have to
live in the state of new hampshire
before you can vote here
effectively you said
so if i move here on election day
and i have bought a house on november
7th i don't actually know what day
election day is next this year
november 8th
whatever i knew would be around there i
wasn't sure exactly the day right um i
guess the counterpoint to that would be
should i if i own it
i moved on my furniture and i own this
home it's election day should i not vote
here do i not have the obligation to the
state of new hampshire where i am
committing myself to be
why are we telling people this is the
place where you're moving to this is the
place where you're committing to but
we're not quite going to let you vote
here yet
um
we have the this idea and i know what
you're going at here this idea that of
the person who stays in the motel for
five minutes and goes back
is breaking the law let's be very clear
about that that is breaking the
definition of domicile it is breaking
the definition of resident under 1264
and 235
that is not
acceptable in new hampshire practice
however
me moving into an apartment or a home
on the day of election day
i'm super dry so i apologize for the
sound here but is accepted practice and
should be because otherwise you're
telling people who have committed to new
hampshire you're saying
great you've committed here but you're
going to have to wait two years before
you can cast a ballot and i would argue
that that is problematic as well
further questions representative sweeney
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my questions
you had stated
that we currently require someone to be
a citizen united states in order to vote
during your testimony and i was
wondering if you or your organization
are aware
in vermont there are a few
municipalities in new york city
they've recently opened up municipal
elections to non-citizen voting
would this this would prohibit such a
move by any municipality in the same new
hampshire would it not
it's i believe already printed in new
hampshire which is where we're talking
about the law is written so
but i'm just saying this would enshrine
in the state's constitution it would but
it's not i do not believe necessary
still
thank you
further questions representative growing
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question if
going back to the primary residence
issue if you take primary at face value
it's it's the main place that you live
uh
would you agree that
for somebody to vote in new hampshire
that should be descriptive of their
right to vote that it is their primary
residence and i think it already is yes
you think that's a ready follow-up madam
chair
you think that's already in statute in
new hampshire i think that for folks who
are voting in new hampshire it is their
primary residence
whatever that i suppose means in statute
okay but
in colloquial terms yes
further questions
representative sweeney thank you thank
you again for indulging us
so what i've gathered from your
testimony in the answers to the
questions is there's nothing
technically new in this constitutional
amendment that differs from existing
state statute in your opinion
well again it depends i guess the
definition of primary residences um
we're adding i'm not sure
a citizen of the state of new hampshire
what that's going to mean for voters who
show up are we going to have to
i don't really know what else we'd have
to prove besides
how you become a citizen of the state of
new hampshire is that just my lease or
is that some other document unclear to
me on what that means
but i think i'm objecting to also to the
principle here which is to say that
these kind of things
uh seem to suggest that there is a
problem with new hampshire elections and
i veemingly disagree with that i'll also
say that after the senate passed this
exact same language i got more than one
fundraising email talking about how
great it was that they were passing this
uh so i think there are you know i think
we gotta focus on issues that
should be focused on follow-up madam
chair follow-up thank you thank you
again um
i just think if if
yes my question is if our elections are
great in new hampshire which i believe
they are should we not enshrine what
current state statute has for our
elections in our constitution so they
can remain great for the foreseeable
future
i would say they are going to remain
great for the foreseeable future there
is nothing that has been presented to me
to suggest otherwise right we are doing
it well in fact i would say that the
elections that we ran during the
pandemic through the hard work of our
local election officials were some of
the most successful elections that we
had seen
and so again it's this idea that there
is something wrong
with our elections that we need to do
something to fix them when we do not and
further questions
see none thank you thank you
go get a drink of water
all right uh let's also sign up to speak
oh i'm sorry representative horgan do
you want to go
sorry
i missed you
oh that that's okay man i'm cheering
i didn't realize you came back in i'm
actually glad uh i'm actually glad uh
former mr o'brien uh he was a
distinguished former member of our
caucus of the uh speaker's staff um was
able to speak first because he asked a
lot of uh
tough tough questions and i'm not sure
whether my intellect is a match for the
especially with the two members in the
corner but i'll do my best and i will
explain why i think this memo is a bad
idea so first of all i'll just say
parenthetically the underlying bill or
resolution whatever you want to call it
um
is a good idea but um
and that's uh but i didn't show up for
that hearing so that that's not what
we're talking about today so the
the um
the proposed non-germain amendment is
identical to senate bill cacr 36 which
will go to the floor actually tomorrow
thursday february 24th
with a three to two ought to pass
recommendation and i'm pretty sure that
was a party line vote
which leads to my
while it's only a rule in the chamber
and not necessarily in in our chain
i try not to talk about the other body
okay i just want to say it's unnecessary
it's in another body uh this proposal is
already you know going through the
legislative process and
it will
if it gets through the other body we're
not allowed to mention it will
eventually uh be here presumably be
referred to your committee the exact
wording right down to the uh right down
to the the commas and periods and
everything so it's it's exactly the same
as
another
resolution in another body and um
so i kind of feel like
just bringing it up here
so it's first of all it's it's just a
waste of time and effort you know we're
all we may already have our chance at
doing it so
my second objection is that's a bad idea
essentially as the phrase and his
primary residency to existing
constitutional language which states
that voters must be domiciled in the
town ward or unincorporated place where
they vote and i'm
like mr o'brien i'm really not sure what
that phrase primary residency means
and it's also unclear to me even a
primary residency means something
i'm
not sure why a person is domiciled in
particular place in new hampshire should
be disqualified from voting simply
because his or her residency is not
quote unquote primary whatever that
adjective is construed to mean
so it definitely seems to me that there
would be some cases where individuals
could now be totally disqualified from
voting anywhere at all if you're
domiciled in one place but you have your
primary residence somewhere else and i'm
assuming the term primary residence
actually means something other than
domicile but you're theoretically be
disqualified from voting in either place
unless of course as i said the term
primary residents construe they have no
meaning at all other than the place for
your domicile in which case this whole
amendment is on is uh unnecessary and
you know i'm also concerned about
student voting um in my
written testimony i talked about what uh
a
member actually if this body said to the
other body and i guess that's kind of uh
not uh
it's not allowed not allowed here so i
respect that but it definitely um
i think it's perceived by me and i think
my perception is accurate that it's uh
at least in part
would prevent so-called out-of-state
college students from voting in new
hampshire and i think there was uh
but the us constitution federal voting
rights on and they're just plain simple
common sense i'll stipulate that college
students must be allowed to vote in the
place where they actually live nine to
12 months out of the year
and um
on the end of those i said before it's
unclear what meaning can or will be
ascribed to the highly ambiguous phrase
thomas out in and has primary residence
in the town ward or incorporated place
it seems to me
that the so-called in-state students
will be in-state students which is um
actually most of the i believe that's
the majority of most of the students
attending colleges here in new hampshire
unh unh i know it's about 50 50. the
community college system is like 95
percent
95 percent in state students and
dartmouth has a significant percentage
of new hampshire residents and i'm not
sure about the others but i'm fairly
safe to say that a majority of the
college students at the colleges
university of new hampshire are in fact
living in new hampshire before they move
somewhere to go to school
so it seems to me they would be deemed
ineligible to vote in the place they
lived before going to college because
either that place they live before
supposedly if you think it's still their
primary residence and i really think
that's probably like why um the sponsors
in the other body introduce this and um
there's things possibly they wouldn't be
able to vote in either place and you
also you can't come to the out of state
students actually being allowed to vote
in the previous state that they lived in
and they
many cases have good reasons to want to
vote
here in new hampshire rather than their
old state that they've left behind and
something else to say about college
students is they often stay for many
many years after they graduate one of
the members of the
stratford county six delegation and i
probably i think i forgot to say at the
beginning that i'm representing timothy
horrigan they all knew that i'm from
stratfor county six the towns of durham
and madbury but at least one of the
state reps from my delegation
moved here from another state in the
1970s has lived in durham continuously
since since so they don't all just go
away as soon as they graduate and i know
um
and um
so anyways i think uh
that's not a good idea from um
so there's definitely is at least the
possibility to disenfranchise both
out-of-state college students and
in-state college students i don't think
either of those are good policy and
probably unconstitutional and violate
federal law
finally
something is
less ambiguous
and i'm assuming it turns out to mean
what the proponents apparently wanted to
mean of course which is a whole question
there it's a very um we're totally
disenfranchised so-called you acaba
voters
secretary scanlan is not here by do you
see deputy
deputy secretary lovejoy she probably
knows a lot more about it than i do but
those are u.s citizens who reside
overseas put in title to vote for
federal office and the last place they
lived before moving out of the united
states usually they fill out a
shortened version of the absentee ballot
because here in new hampshire you can
only vote for the federal offices some
states do let you vote for the state
offices and
i suppose the yuakov voter could
theoretically fly back to new hampshire
and vote in their old hometown and then
fly back to where they live but
so that's definitely
that's not even ambiguous in my mind
i've looked at the yo kava law on the
guidelines so that's uh a direct
this amendment
one amendment can't be unconstitutional
but it can definitely conflict with
federal law and we we would have like a
pretty um
yeah we hate to be sued we probably
would be sued if we if this amendment
was became part of the constitution
and
[Music]
so finally my third objection
is that it's an insult to the sponsors
the underlying version of cacf r15 who
are trying to encourage young people to
vote by allowing 17 year olds to vote in
the primary election if they will be 18
by the day of the general election
so i will close by quoting what one of
cfr 15 sponsors my friend and colleague
representative sherry frost said to me
when i asked her about this amendment
and she specifically uh
she specifically authorized me to quote
her she responded simply quote ugg so
this is this is definitely it's like i'm
i believe probably the other uh
sponsored vision will probably feel the
same way they might not have expressed
themselves quite bluntly but you know
you know oh it's definitely um
it's
definitely um not in not in line with
the spirit of the original bill and we i
mean we do non-germane amendments that
reverse the attend the original bill all
the time and even germain amendments but
still it's it's not a good legislative
practice and it should be avoided and
frankly it's uh
it's an insult to the members who worked
hard to bring the original uh resolution
forward so with um
so that i think it's pretty clear that
this bill should be itl i'd be happy to
take any questions
thank you representative horrigan
questions representative sweeney thank
you thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for taking my question um
the first part of your testimony and the
the crux of the previous speaker's
testimony in my opinion uh was that this
constitutional amendment is enshrining
current practice and state statute into
our state's constitution we had record
turnout in 2020 under your perception
that you got to in the second half of
your testimony
how many people do you think that were
eligible to vote in 2020 under the state
statutes that were enshrining in our
constitution would now somehow not be
eligible to vote in future elections
my
my guess is if you share my
interpretation of the language it's zero
but obviously this has been introduced
for some reason to correct some problem
and um
perhaps i'm guessing wrong what it is so
it's obvious
yeah so i
it depends on
it depends on how it's construed and
what sort of law is uh you know probably
some statute law would be passed in
response to it of course this doesn't
kick in until 2024 anyways i mean
if you do it really really literally in
my opinion
domicile is the same thing as primary
residents and so uh this bill's total
you know this resolution is totally
unnecessary so there's no point you know
there's no point in reword just
rewording it in a way that's less clear
so follow up madam chair thank you
follow up so to just to first distinct
answer zero voters would be
disenfranchised
don't hold me to it but i'm i'm
it will would
most likely be zero but i i don't want
to take a chance on it it could be you
know it could be thousands of them
depending on uh
um
yes um thank you um madam chairman uh
thank you representative um you
mentioned college students in your
testimony where in the bill does it
unfortunately i can't refer to the
debate in the other body so that issue
came up in the cas 36 debate but that's
not an issue here but that was about a
amendment a resolution that's exactly
the same
right down to every comma
every dot over every i every cross over
every t so it's exactly identical to
that resolution which will be voted on
in another legislative body tomorrow and
certainly with that one
um
i just know that i just know it's a
controversial issue and it did it did
come up in another legislative body
thank you representative horrigan
further questions
um
yes one representative um you mentioned
let's not talk about college students
for a second let's talk about people who
spend nine out of the 12 months here in
new hampshire effectively by your
admission having primary residency in
the state which
is a tacit admission about how that
there is some length of time you should
live here before you vote here um but
that aside
my my question is is
is if if these people who are spending
the majority of their time here
and are voting here and nobody's
disputing as you're not disputing and
i'm not disputing they have a right to
vote here shouldn't they be doing the
other things that new hampshire
residents do like getting a new
hampshire driver's license with your
correct address on it registering your
car here in new hampshire shouldn't
residents of the state who are voting in
new hampshire elections be doing the
things that every other resident does
and if they're not
what makes these people special to not
have to do these things that other
residents are doing
well those um those two things you
mentioned are very very minor motor
vehicle violations they're not they're
not felonies and um
and uh i'm probably this is a topic
which actually was the subject of
another uh another piece of legislation
another committee
just yesterday but um
the
in terms of the driver's license we were
part of a uh
we're part of a compact with every other
state and we have reciprocal agreements
with every other state and actually all
the canadian provinces that
one jurisdiction's driver's license is
as good as another for the purposes of
uh identificat of a
proving well first of all that you're a
qualified driver and that you have uh
you
and that your identification so for that
regard
basically if you have a out of state
driver's license you're basically it's
as good as an in-state driver's license
you just have the old address on it and
certainly
um
you know those are minor motor vehicle
violations and sometimes there are you
know especially with the car sometimes
the reasons why
a student in particular they're driving
a car that's owned by another family
member and it's difficult to register it
but that's that's an extremely minor
motor vehicle violation it's not a
felony it's not something that would
normally disqualify you to vote and
nobody would really care
nobody really cares if a unh student
registers to vote with their uh
safety move from to durham
yeah
as for the durational requirement i'm
i'm happy with the the current law so
all right
thank you
i'm not seeing any other questions thank
you representative horrigan oh thank you
and uh signed up as the final speaker
thank you for this opportunity to speak
before you i'm liz tentarelli i'm
president of the nonpartisan league of
women voters
and our job is to help people understand
how they vote
i think most of the committee members
know how they want to vote on this i'm
going to ask you to try to amend the
amendment in one way only
and that is get rid of the phrase a
citizen of new hampshire
i don't have a passport from new
hampshire
i was not born here i don't know how i'd
prove that i am a citizen of new
hampshire
so i got very annoyed sorry that's wrong
i was disturbed when i saw this
amendment
and i guess i had too much time on my
hands because i started googling through
the rsas
for citizen
and the only place i found citizen of
new citizen of new hampshire
was in some of the very very old parts
of the
statutes that defined who may hold
certain offices
so this probably is a phrase that was
used back in the 1800s
it is not a phrase we use now
and if in my role with the league of
women voters i'm trying to explain to
people
who may vote
i can easily explain citizen of the
united states people understand that you
were either born here or you were
naturalized
citizen
i don't know how to explain citizen of
new hampshire
and unless we're going to start issuing
passports i can't explain it
so please consider eliminating that
phrase which has essentially no meaning
for voting purposes
thank you
further questions
representative lane
um thank you madam chair and thank you
miss tentarelli um
does the term primary residence
give you any pause
it's a tough one to explain to people
um
we have used the word domiciled
and that too is confusing to many
would-be voters it's not a term we
commonly use
so when i try in the simplest language
possible to make voting accessible to
the most people
i say you need to offer some evidence of
where you live
and i leave it at that
and
i realize that's not what the statutes
say
but i have to work with people who need
to understand things so yeah primary
residence domicile
those may be legal terms
they're not very helpful to the average
person who now is eligible to vote
thank you
representative barry um yes thank you
madam chairman and
primary residency domicile
what do you think is more confusing
which one is more ambiguous do you
believe which one's which one's better
i mean that's that's a phrase that
people understand where you live yeah
thank you for this oh i'm sorry
further questions representative growing
thank you madam chair
so the proposed amendment here says that
a person
is a citizen of new hampshire
only if that person is domiciled in and
has primary residence in the town ward
an incorporated place
isn't that the definition of citizen of
new hampshire that you would be looking
for
doesn't this define it quite clearly
it's not a phrase that i've ever seen
before i've never been asked are you a
citizen of new hampshire
and i would guess most of the people in
this room have not been asked that
question
you may have been asked where do you
live
but you're not asked if you're a citizen
of new hampshire you're a citizen of the
united states i assume
you're saying where what is your
citizenship you say united states not
new hampshire
so i'm asking
this committee to consider
making this language something that
makes sense to the vast majority of
people who are eligible to vote
but need to know that they are eligible
to vote
further questions
i will just point out that i think when
they did this the second or third time
which got us into this mess they thought
they were being perfectly clear then too
so
any other questions for liz tentarelli
thank you very much thank you you want
to press the button liz so the red is
off thanks
yes representative wayne um
i find myself in the awkward position
that we're not able
to uh
ask
questions of the of you as the person
who put forth this amendment
is is that a procedural
you can go ahead okay
sorry i just just for purposes of
conducting the hearing i know i know i
understand okay representative barry
does that a lot
yeah we constantly putting people down
there
okay
so
so i would like to ask about these
phrases that um just that disturbed me
and caused me because i also looked at
primary residence as a
red flag
because it implies there is a secondary
residence and the term primary residence
is not defined in 1260 well i don't even
know the statute but the bill 1264 right
not not the one that we have to perforce
now but
so
if we're going to do a constitutional
amendment i would like it to be
more clear than this language
thank you for the question
some of this had to do with what what
you we just heard someone refer to as
being what people are comfortable with
and understand and so in the hope that
the adjective primary the use of it as
an adjective was going to clarify things
because we also have had discussions and
case law referring to people who have
multiple places where they lay their
head
the attempt was to distinguish that
and i think it's pretty clear by virtue
of the fact we've got some other bills
in front of us who actually talk about
nights of the year or something from a
time standpoint so that was the hope but
as we have public hearings we always
learn that things we think we're clear
are not
and the citizen language
actually
goes back to
comments that have been received or
discussed in regards to
the origins of it to begin with and that
there has been historical use of the
term citizen
and that it does have an historical
meaning
and that maybe use of it in this
generation after hearing common is not
appropriate but that was the intent was
and i apologize to committee members for
that but i think we ask questions to
representative muirhead on the on the
question of new hampshire citizenship um
it's something i do take seriously
though i think of it as symbolic rather
than a legal thing
and i wondered if i if i could ask you
whether you agree with me in that
respect
for instance
i grew up in manchester new hampshire
and as a grown-up i um
i was compelled to live in texas for a
number of years in order to make a
living and although texas is a great
state it's not as great as the state of
new hampshire
so when i lived there i consider myself
a citizen of red sox nation
and refused to root for the rangers
the whole while i was there and i also
considered myself a citizen of new
hampshire
even though i was residing in in texas
and uh and i think that was a fair thing
to do uh because it's a kind of state of
mind and a symbolic status and
and i wonder if you would agree that
that
category of citizenship of new hampshire
should be
maintained that way as a
as a an allegiance and a state of mind
and a symbolic thing rather than a legal
thing
and that would be my answer
representative barry
more of a statement than a common chair
just want to say i agree with
representative meerhead as a native
texan i do agree that new hampshire is
do i get to add in i lived in houston i
agree
anything else from anybody madam chair
anybody else on the non-germain
amendment public hearing
seeing none i'm going to close the
public hearing we are going to be in
recess for 15 minutes and then we will
i was never told who i was subbing for
all right thank you everybody we are
the house election law committee we are
back from recess we are starting our 11
o'clock executive session
a little late we have a number of bills
on before i begin this
the next date of executive session will
be march
9th
it will be only executive session
and it will be a long day for us for
executive session there are a number of
bills
many of them having to do with election
processes
um because we have some
communities with some
items on the
voting list for the 8th so we're going
to be here on the 9th but if you've
looked at your calendar things need to
be done
so that will be our next date
back here
we've gone through substitutes our first
bill
on the list to be exact this afternoon
is cacr 22
relating to elections providing that all
elections in new hampshire shall be by
rank choice voting i'm going to open up
the discussion on that and include h.b
1264 for comments from committee members
that is also a bill establishing rank
choice voting for state party primary
elections and municipal elections so
they are both dealing with ranked choice
voting we've already had one bill
that
went to session and was voted on last
week
but these two are also ranked choice
voting they are doing something slightly
different and at this time before i take
any
um
i'm trying to think it's any who's the
real parliamentary can i open discussion
without having a motion on the floor
representative bergeron
i do not view myself as a
parliamentarian madam chair i think as
the chair you can issue whatever
procedures and rules you wish and unless
someone challenges you we're going to
abide by those all right i'm taking a
look at those open windows
deciding
so
before we have any emotion i am going to
open the floor for committee members to
discuss this
and
representative bergeron has raised his
hand
in regards to it so i'm going to
consider this time open for discussion
on both bills in regards to rank choice
voting representative bergeron thank you
madam chair
to kind of set the table if
i might
i am going to vote against the cacr
i don't think a constitutional amendment
is needed at this time
i think it's unnecessary i think that
language could be written and submitted
in fact has been
to create rank choice voting situations
in state law
and it's not necessary to
tamper with the constitution to direct
that the shall occur
on house bill 1264 however that's
primarily enabling legislation and if
the opportunity arises i would like to
submit an amendment to that
uh which would address some of the
issues i had with house bill 1264
initially uh particularly dealing with
the process by which uh
the political parties and municipalities
could choose to use rank choice voting
in their particular arenas and also to
ensure that
there was a way to rescind that action
at a future point in time if they
decided well after all ranked choice
voting really wasn't working for us and
would like to uh
would like to go back to the way things
used to be so
that's just in an effort to set the
table for discussion if if i may
representative barry yes i'm not going
to speak at length about this but to
address i disagree with the
representative from nashua's
response about cacr22 i think if you
were to implement ranked choice voting i
do actually think you would need a
constitutional amendment um the state
constitution specifically outlines
plurality for certain state races
pluralities is
a power is pro plurality is what it
means which is the person who has the
most votes it's not majority plurality
is not majority so i do i do disagree i
mean we're going to vote the same way
but for different reasons but i just i
don't want to leave that on the table
that i actually think if you were to do
this for all races you would need a cacr
okay
other comments
come on
um for those of you who don't know she
didn't raise her hand but i know
how that she feels very strongly about
this bill so
thank you for recognizing me
um i'm supporting i
would be voting against cacr22
but i am supporting
uh
whatever it is
1264 1264.
um
i believe that rank choice
voting makes election elections more
representative of the will of the people
than the first pass to post system that
it gives voters the freedom to vote
their conscience
it discourages negative campaigning
and it helps to cure a divided society
and i think that's the main reason why
we need rank choice voting
um
our country is divided uh
the partisanship has become hyper
partisan
the gridlock in congress is
causing them to not be able to get
anything done
and there's a lot of public distrust and
dis dissatisfaction of government
so rank choice voting
would
not necessarily solve all the problems
at once but it's a step in the right
direction
to
um
it incentivizes candidates
to reach across the aisle and find
common ground and attract support from
more voters they need to get the
need to get you know over 50 of the vote
in order to win
um
and the same as
so then if they're elected with over 50
of the book they have more support when
they're in office
and they have more reason to
reach across the aisle and try and work
out agreements with with other with
other other people
ranked choice voting can help to cure a
divided society and i believe that
that's the main reason why we need to
move forward
and allow this opportunity to enable
the municipalities and the parties to
try it out if they choose to
thank you thank you
representative terezian
i disagree as far as making um
negative campaigning um
less than what it is now and the reason
i say that
in a primary election
uh it's no secret that most candidates
if they're in a
a primary whether it's contested
the best way to win that primary is to
to to put forth a candidate who
relates with
party leaders in that in that
whatever whether it's a democrat or
republican
primary
and statistics bear that out um that the
four four and three four voters are the
most likely to go so if you want to win
that primary you're going to really
message to those folks
so on one hand you're going to be very
partisan but then in the general
election
under ranked choice
neutral or in the middle of the road and
tell everybody what they want to hear
that doesn't necessarily mean you're
going to get a better candidate you're
going to get a candidate that tells you
what you want to hear more but that
doesn't necessarily mean that
that candidate is going to be a better
candidate i mean
let's face it look at the poll numbers
on politicians the average american
doesn't trust what they say anyway so i
i don't know that that's going to really
achieve
that
if it would i
would be in favor but this time i'm i'm
representative bergeron why don't you
take us through the amendment it's
amendment zero seven
six nine
sure um
this would amend section 11 of house
bill 1264
which in the original bill is titled
applicability this one the new title is
applicability and implementation
the major changes are
first of all as far as the party goes it
makes it clear that it's up to the
parties to decide uh how what process
they want to use to come to the decision
that they want to use ranked choice
voting but then directs that the
party chair or designee shall notify the
secretary of state of their choice to
conduct rank choice voting in their
primary just the primary election
and uh each party can act independently
whatever one party chooses does not
apply to the situation of another party
i would say that um generally i've
always supported any bill that lets the
parties decide how they want to go about
choosing the candidates for the general
election
so this would be consistent with
positions i've taken in the past
uh on on bills dealing with how the
parties are going to
choose their designees
uh i thought it was unclear in the
original bill uh which is addressed in
the amendment in section three how towns
and cities needed to come to a
conclusion that they wanted to try
ranked choice voting
as i read the original bill it almost
sounded like the board of selectmen or
city council could take a vote and
decide to implement rank choice voting
but i wanted it to to go to the voters
so that the voters are actually making
that decision themselves so in section
three
a question has to be put to the voters
if whether or not they want to use rank
choice voting
and
in the towns that would
and most cities that would just be by a
warrant article a referendum
initiative petition whatever process
that community uses to put the question
on the ballot
i did include an exception for cities
that might need changes to their
charters
specifically i'm thinking of the cities
of manchester and nashua which
have primaries set up for some of their
elections
in manchester it's when two or when more
than two candidates are running for a
single seat they have to have a primary
for that race
and in nashua there's a primary in place
for the office of the mayor
um the state constitution i think it's
part second article 39
says that no changes can be made to a
municipal charter
unless the a question is put before the
voters of the community and they vote to
approve that change
so there is an exception here saying
that if a charter amendment needs to be
done to accomplish or institute rank
choice voting then that will have to be
done through the charter amendment
process
and then later on if the communities
wanted to reverse
the choice they go through the same
process they put it to a vote of the
voters
and i think that's
pretty much what the amendment's trying
comments representative sweeney
thank you madam chair um
i think like i've gathered most of the
room we'll be voting against cacr22
i'll also be voting against hb 1264.
i did get a number of calls about it
from both sides in support and opposed
to ranked choice voting
and i have a number of issues
with it i could see the argument for
state party primaries i really could i
could see the argument for
even without legislation internally how
state parties organize themselves when
they elect their state party leadership
i have great hesitation and i would say
the crux of my reason to not vote for
1264.
either as the amended version or as as
originally proposed
the the potential of jeopardizing our
presidential primary
i think is at severe risk due to this
legislation
a couple years back there was a great
project from new hampshire public radio
called stranglehold
and they had a series of episodes
talking about iconic new hampshire
primary moments i mean one of those
episodes centered on the the magic of
the new hampshire presidential primary
night when regular granite staters and
activists from the campaign stood on
stage with a successful or winning
or even third place finisher
in the respective party's presidential
primary
and that candidate got to declare
victory in new hampshire and then the
headlines the next morning across the
country would say
bill clinton is the comeback kid from
new hampshire or john mccain the
maverick shocks the nation uh in
manchester
with ranked choice voting that would
delay the results from our presidential
primary uh we wouldn't have it the night
of the election nobody would get beyond
unless they were the incumbent
officeholder
and so we would not have a scenario in
which we would have in a multi-candidate
presidential primary the results on the
night of the election we might have to
wait up to a week south carolina and
nevada could be voting before we have
the final results from the new hampshire
presidential primary
and to me that is a risk in this
legislation that i'm not willing to take
at this time i think this jeopardizes
our position as first in the nation uh
because it would be we vote first but
then we get the results third or second
um and that's not something that i would
want to entertain
but i do want to specify
it is a concept that i am not
innately opposed to
and i did hear from people on both sides
i do know that that supporters of this
had been seeing this as a stepping stone
to implement it fully down the road into
general elections uh and again i'm not
there yet um and i'm not sure if i ever
will be
but i'm not making this decision lightly
this isn't a you know oh i don't like it
so i'm voting against it i do want to
say and i think all the members here uh
really thoroughly
uh discuss this among themselves thought
it through in their conditions and i
wanted to spell out why i would be
supporting a motion of an expedient to
legislate on 1264.
representative hamlet
thank you madam chair
um
rain choice voting would not necessarily
take a week we think we can have the
results the same night there's there's
nothing that would prevent that from
happening in utah they have the results
the same night
um
or i would say the very latest the next
morning but i think probably we can have
the results the same night once
um so
the if
if in the first round of votes a
candidate gets over 50 50 that that
candidate is going to win the nominee
you know it's going to win
if it has to
uh if nobody gets over 50 and has to go
into a second round
um
the local elections
uh
you know local polls don't handle that
the results go directly to the secretary
of estate
which then would put it into a
high-speed tabulator which would
very quickly
calculate the next round
and
uh so i and the only thing that might
take time is until we get our new voting
machines which we'll be getting anyway
the um
you know the results would be have to
would have to be uh courier to the
secretary of state's office in a secure
courier i mean it could all be done very
securely
um so i it's not going to take a week it
can be done the same night or very
quickly
um so i that is not a problem and
otherwise it doesn't change anything
about
anything else about the primary
presidential primary
representative alexander
um thank you madam chair
um i have some serious concerns with
ranked choice voting i think like uh
what what represented hamlet just
mentioned with the um courier um i mean
i think there's already problems like
there's perceived problems with how
ballots are counted and transferring
transporting microchip microchips from
lancaster new hampshire down to concord
first of all won't happen that night but
um if it did it's it's transporting that
to a secure central location for
counting and typically in the past
we would report unofficial results out
of towns and then the secretary of state
would certify it later
the other problem i have is that ranked
choice voting doesn't always guarantee a
majority i think if you have a buy-in
from
100 of the voters it would
guarantee a majority but if you have a
bunch of voters that go in and vote in
the first round
and then only some voters vote in the
second third fourth fifth round then it
actually isn't a majority after the
first round um so that's where i have an
issue with that um so it just requires a
lot of buy-in from the voters i don't
think the voters are necessarily there
yet um so i'll be voting now thank you
representative murrahood
i just understand the presidential
primary um
rules
it's i don't think the case that that uh
you know i think the national the
national party uh the national parties
would have a lot to say about how the
nominees would be would be selected and
they'd have a lot of influence so i
don't think this bill would be inviting
our presidential primaries to be run by
representative hamlet
so uh ranked choice voting does ensure
uh support from the most voters and i
think that's what we want we want a
candidate that has
support from the most voters possibly
you know them
all right all right representative barry
um
i'm glad the logistics of ranked choice
voting were brought up and uh real
representative by the way thank you for
your phone call representative um we had
a long conversation and you know my
concerns are
logistical so i i do want to push back
on the notion that if we were doing a
statewide race that we would have
results that night or the next day um it
assumes a couple of things the first of
which is that every single town has a
machine
they do not so the secretary of state's
office will be counting hand ballots for
ranked choice voting for i think it's
about a third of our towns correct um
it's not a third of the votes but it's a
third of the towns
that's not insignificant
i also brought up for the point of we
talk about the presidential primary and
i really have avoided trying to do the
argument of presidential primary because
i think it gets it there's very times
it's legitimate i think there are
legitimate concerns here but a lot of
times it's not uh but here i think there
are some but let's talk about the state
primary for a second let's talk about
2016.
2016 the race for republican governor
had a four-way race um
then executive councilor uh chris sununu
uh state senator jeannie forrester uh
former man
then current manchester mayor um
uh ted gatsas and state representative
frank edelblut um for those paying
attention at home uh representative
edelblut got within i believe it was 600
or 800 votes
of um
of uh counselor sununu at the time
and he was well within his right to
request a recount he ultimately chose
not to um but let's let's say for the
sake of argument that we used ranked
choice voting and he got within 800
votes
well we wouldn't know until two or three
days later um because of the hand
counting of votes the bringing the
bringing of the memory cards down to
concord um or wherever serialization it
would be and probably be conquered
and then he requests a recount well now
with our abbreviated primary window we
have a six to seven week primary window
it's usually about six weeks now we've
now we're conducting a hand a recount
needs to be by hand right so now we're
hand counting ranked choice vote ballots
and we've missed three days in an
already extraordinarily abbreviated
window um that doesn't work um it
basically you're just handing the
election off to the other side by the
way if if it happened to my colleagues
on the other side we'd be saying oh yeah
you should recount this and give up a
week of campaigning see what happens um
you know when you're giving up 18 of
your campaign window as the general
election nominee that's a problem so
there are my concerns with this are
overwhelmingly logistical i do not think
and and the
the 1264 by their own admission um
people who support it
it's the they are they're trying to open
the door to get it statewide
if you want to go statewide with ranked
choice voting there are so many things
that you have to fix
you're going to have to you're going to
have to if you want speedy results
you're going to have to transmit results
over the internet we literally just
voted against that like we literally
just voted that down um so
there are there it is a logistical
nightmare with the way we currently
conduct our elections um you can make
the argument on a town level it's fine
it'll just clarify it goes away but once
again the overarching goal of the
sponsors is to get it to statewide and
you're just not there so i'll be
representative hamlet
um so
first of all the secretary of state does
not hand count the votes the secretary
of state uses their high speed tabulator
so that's not going to be an issue
and also it currently takes days for the
secretary of state's office to certify
certified the election
so
you know the the immediate results can
representative terezian thank you madam
chair just to refresh the committee's
memory when we heard testimony on the
other ranked choice
bill that we had
earlier in the
a couple weeks ago
we heard testimony that in maine
this was from the assistant secretary of
state
that um
it takes a
a week
to get the results
and
we also heard that they do have to
transport
those ballots to a central location in
that
i agree with earlier uh testimony that
that's problematic the more you move
ballots the more change you have of
a risk of losing ballots or misplacing
something whether intentional otherwise
that
i think is a needless
thing to have to do if
i want to remind everybody that we're in
a time when
a fairly percentage fairly big
percentage of people
in the state are concerned about voter
integrity so anything we can do to
to help get that
confidence back is a good thing anything
we do that potentially
gives a perception that
ballots moving around and that uh things
could be lost and things could get
misplaced and so forth is not not a good
thing so
that's just another reason why i'm
representative lane
um thank you madam chair
um this is only an enabling bill
somebody would have to just to try it
out
we're never going to get comfortable
with something new if we don't give
people the opportunity to try it out
and
whether or not
and some of the some of the
issues that have been raised may be
legitimate but we are not going to know
if we don't try it and i guess and i
don't see how it impacts voter integrity
so i i
i just feel like we should try something
new and it has worked in australia for
40 years it's worked all over this
country
in in municipal elections all over so
i don't see what we're scared of but
anyway
representative hamlet
in maine they it takes day it takes
several days a week or whatever to
um come up with their results because
they allow
a week
in new hampshire
we have to have the results of the
election in within 20 i don't know if
it's 24 or 48 hours but it's
it's uh it's very quick we don't allow a
week
so and it can be done in a week and it's
done in other states i mean it can be
done in a day and it's done in other
states it's done in utah
in the same night the elect the
votes are tabulated the same night
also as far as the voter integrity
problem
or issue
is that um i believe
that what those the voters that are
worried about the voter integrity i
think what they really want to know is
that their vote counted
and
um with ranked choice voting every vote
counts
the tabulations are completely
transparent they're published statewide
to every voter to see how their votes so
every voter can see how their votes
factored in
and
well
if you you know have had a chance to
read
ellen reed's uh
results of our our mock chocolate
election that we had
she
uh gave great a great graphic and great
explanations of how
um how the runoff rounds work and it's
just so clear you can see exactly how it
there's there's no voter integrity
problem here so i think what the voter
integrity people need to know is that
their vote counted
and ranked choice voting ensures that
representative terrorism thank you madam
chair
well i would say that right now every
vote does count
now if you're in a ranked choice
environment
you may get to vote
say for six different choices but at the
end of the day you still could be as a
voter end up with somebody that you
didn't pick
so
if
your vote counts but that you don't
necessarily get the person that you want
and
if you're making several choices one
could argue that
you could say
jesus
you know i've i got six choices and my
vote still doesn't count because i
didn't get the person i want so i think
that
that's you know somewhat misleading as
far as the voter integrity the only
reason i brought it up is be because
again in the state of maine maybe we can
do it faster i don't know but they said
that it took them that long not
necessarily because
just because we don't have that long to
do it doesn't mean we can get it done in
an earlier period of time i heard no
testimony that suggested we could do it
quicker that's all thanks
representative growing
thank you madam chair um
i
i have been
looking at this for many years i was
actually
first introduced to the idea of ranked
choice voting in 2010
of all places at an alec convention
in washington dc
and uh there are a number of people
there it was not a uh
you know part of a presentation or
anything but it was uh
a number of people
with a small booth talking about it and
i was intrigued by it because in a
number especially in the in the
presidential primary number of times i
wanted to vote for a candidate that i
really
was excited about but i was concerned
that if i voted for that candidate that
um
a
a less conservative and i'm i'm very
conservative and i i was concerned that
a less conservative candidate would win
and so i would not vote for the one i
really wanted to so i was intrigued by
i am concerned here in new hampshire
uh with our current system our current
machines
uh
the amount of hand voting that's done
on
how efficient the process would be i'm i
agree with representative berry in that
area that the process
is
it's going to be difficult to overcome
uh
however
that's
part of the reason why i'm going to
support 1264.
um
this is an is enabling legislation
it allows us to test this
on a
small
in a smaller setting uh
it
with with the uh
representative bergeron's amendment it
gives a fairly detailed process for
cities or towns to implement this if
the political parties can choose or not
choose to do it it gives us a chance to
test it if this does not work if it's
just too complex and there are too many
problems
this legislature
will look at it again and can vote and
can say we're going to end ranked choice
voting
and
so
it it seems to me that this is a process
that has merit to test a concept you
know we've we've heard often that states
are the laboratories of democracy
because we can test ideas before they go
to the federal level in in a sense i i
feel the same way about this
i do have some concerns about the
constitutionality
of it um
but i see that both ways i
we are we are starting
uh
with the process as we are and i don't
see that our
present wording in the constitution
require requiring a plurality
for bids
going another step to bring it to either
a higher plurality or a majority so um
i i am not going to vote for cacr 22 i
agree with both uh
that that
it's certainly
i don't believe that's it there's a
place for that right now but i am going
to vote for hb 1264
um and i do favor representative
representative terozan thank you madam
chair
so if this bill was just to have a test
of the system without be you know
involving an actual election i probably
could support it
but
if any i understand it's enabling
legislation but for for
municipalities or parties that decide to
use it
it
it's re it will be real if it's used and
and that's another concern i have is the
inconsistency so you may have a
situation in your town where your town
decides they want to use this
but the
the party that you identify with doesn't
use it so when you go to
depending on what election you're going
to
you you may not um
it's just one more thing to confuse the
voter
gee in this election i get to choose
up to five people and the other one i
don't it just i think it muddies the
water
further discussion
um
i'm just going to say a couple of things
one i continue to have concerns about
page seven of the bill
paragraph eight that refers to general
elections because it was my
understanding this was intended to only
apply to primary and i think that was
brought up because i have notes on it so
i don't see anything taking that
reference out
in regards to the references to utah
utah uses something called direct
recording electronic voting
at least in some of its
areas which would be exactly what this
committee voted not to do
and there was currently there was
legislation to go back to all paper in
utah i'm not sure what the status is but
certainly their history
is that they have electronic vote
recording which i think
given the size of this state and votes
we just took you can't equate the two i
don't think you can get away from the
fact that there are logistical issues
in doing this
um
admittedly
under the proposal in 1264 at the
discretion of
who decides to do it
and while the municipality may bear that
expense in regards to local elections
the state would certainly bear that
expense in regards to primary
and i will echo what i think i've heard
is that i think a lot of this is to
my vote counts is the fact people are
that's the bottom line what i think and
i think it it started about eight years
ago
um
and
i think that's that's what's going on
with the my vote counted because
um
i i think what you're you're saying is
more people will have filled in an oval
for someone who won
and that therefore somehow that makes
them think their vote counted as
compared to just filling in the oval for
one
and i would suggest to you when we just
had a hearing on a bill
that voters could not figure out
appropriately how to fill out ovals for
multiple candidates
that asking them to fill out ovals in a
ranking order is something that
maybe is not a road we should be going
down
so
um those are sort of my comments
representative hamblin
so um
in all the recent um
ranked choice elections that have
happened around the country
um the exit polls have shown that
the voters said it was easy to
understand
and the um man phil steele from maine
who testified at the hearing
he said
at the conceptual level voters have zero
difficulty understanding
that rank choice voting gives them the
opportunity to express their preferences
among candidates
i.e candidate smith is my first choice
candidate jones is my second choice
voters can figure that out
and
the second point was that when given a
properly designed ranked choice voting
ballot and instructions
voters have very little difficulty
understanding how to mark the ballot the
ballot so i i don't
i don't think voters will be concerned
further discussion on the ranked choice
i'm not seeing any so i think at this
point it would
be
appropriate for a motion
the first bill would be cacr 22 is there
madam chair i i move cacr 22 itl i
believe that can i have a second a
second the motion madam chair
thank you
ed would you like to speak to yourself
thank you madam chair um
i believe this would enshrine in our
constitution something that is untested
and
needs a lot more thought before we'd
even consider doing that
i do believe that
it may be required moving forward
um
but it's certainly not for today
any other discussion on the motion the
i'm not seeing any further discussion on
the motion i'm going to ask the clerk to
representative mcdonald yes yes
red
yes
representative sweeney yes
representative mooney
yes
representative
yes representative
yes
representative
yes representative
yes
marcus yes
representative
page yes
representative ward
yes
representative bergeron yes
representative pimentel
yes
representative hamer yes representative
lane yes
representative freitas yes
representative hamlet yes
representative murrahad
cacr22 will go uh to the
house session as
recommended by this committee
inexpedient to legislate
without objection that will go on the
consent calendar
all right the next bill before us is
1264.
there was an amendment presented today
to the committee representative bergeron
do you have a motion
thank you madam chair yes i moved to
amend house bill 1264 with amendment
is there a second
representative hamlet
okay
is there would you like to speak to the
motion representative bergeron
no i don't think that's necessary thank
you
all right is there any further
discussion on the amendment
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call for the vote this would be
to amend 1264. the amendment number is
769.
o'brien
thanks
yes
representative sweeney
no
yes
representative lane yes representative
freitas
yes
representative hamlet yes
send me your head
the amendment carries uh 14 to six so 12
64 is on the floor
um as amended
is there a motion manager on 1264
representative lane yep i have a motion
to pass with the amendment
representative hamlet second second
like representative bergeron i don't
think that's necessary i would point out
that
as
representative growing point out this is
a way for us to test it and it is only
all right any further discussion i'm
going to ask the clerk to call the role
this will be 1264
representative mcdonald no
representative o'brien no
representative sweeney no
representative hayward
oh sorry this is an old paper a
representative
no
no representative barry no
yes
representative quailey no
clerk is no
representative alexander no
representative page
yes
representative ward yes
yes representative lane yes represent
freitas yes
and hamlet yes rips him your head yes
madam chair
no
so it's a 10-10 right
the motion fails and it's on the floor
open to further motion representative
thank you madam chair
i make a motion
to find
house bill 1264 in expedient to
legislate
is there a second
it's been moved and seconded to be
thank you madam chair and i'll try not
to reiterate several things that we
were spoken of earlier
um
and while again there's you know i can
see
there's some interesting aspects of this
idea
but at this time i can't support the
idea for a number of the reasons you had
heard and for a few others
and i mentioned this before in the last
ranked choice vote
voting uh bill that we had that
i am somebody that goes out and
campaigns door-to-door uh very
frequently
and one of the things i find and i'm in
a district with four
four reps
many people
don't even know who their reps are
number one number two they're lucky if
they could
identify one that is
so i think that it's less than
scientific when you get into a ranked
choice vote situation where now you have
to vote for at least double the number
of people that's number one number two
one of the things we heard on this
one of the
ideas or one of the reasons that people
like this is that it helps a third party
candidate
potentially get in when they can
otherwise but we also heard testimony
from the folks that came down from maine
that not one third party candidate has
won an election since
they they adopted ranked choice voting
and that leads me into a point that
um the constitution
currently is clear that you can win an
election by the plurality of the vote
when maine first adopted this they had
to uh
became it was a rep or a senate race
where
that individual won the first round by
the plurality yet after they did some of
these so-called runoffs he lost the
election so that would be problematic in
new hampshire where
the constitution says plurality it does
not say majority so anytime you have a
scheme that's going to require a
majority that's going to be a problem
and
i won't reiterate but i i do believe
that there is a
problem time wise with getting the
the count done election day
and while we heard testimony that many
towns
that we need to replace our
vote counting machines many towns have
ones that are still functional and and
don't need to be replaced i understand
many do but that's that's
there are many that
if we adopt this would have to
um replace their machines even if
they're not to the point of needing
needing to be done
and the other thing which i mentioned
before but i'll just touch on very
briefly is that
again adding to the potential for
confusion
you could very well with this because
it's enabling legislation have
one election where you're voting where
it's it's the way we do it now
and the other election so there's down
election maybe the way we do it now the
primary election may be ranked choice so
you're flip flipping back and forth it's
inconsistent i think that's generally
speaking not a good policy to have
uh or
set up a process that could lend itself
to more confusion
um with the way we do things and one
last thing and i'll shut up is that i
value our uh first the
nation presidential primary and i do
believe this would if we adopt this
um
it could put that at jeopardy and the
very last thing is that uh i do believe
if we adopt this that it will lead to a
gateway to have rank choice voting in
the general election as well
thanks
any further discussion on the motion it
is this is on the floor as amended 1264
and the motion on the floor is itl
representative hamlet
yes i would just like to respond
um to representative teroshan's comments
[Music]
there is nothing in 1264 that's against
the new hampshire constitution
and
also i think the offices you're worried
about are state general elections
not this is only for municipal and
party primaries
thank you okay
further discussion
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll
the bill on the floor is 1264. as
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative mooney
yes
representative
representative barry yes
representative growing
no
representative quailey yes
represent
clerk yes
representative alexander yes
uh representative page
no
representative ward no
representative bergeron no
representative
no
representative hamer no
representative lane no
representative freitas no representative
hamlet no
represent
having had a vote 10 to 10 otpa an abode
10 to 10 itl
this will go to the floor with amendment
the next bill for executive session here
this morning
nope this afternoon
is 1324 establishing a formula to
allocate presidential electors to the to
presidential nominees is there a motion
representative barry yes ma'am chairman
i move that hp 1324 be inexpediant to
legislate is there a second second that
madam chair
it's been moved and seconded would you
like to speak to your motion uh yes
ma'am very briefly um ironically enough
this legislation would probably help my
party but ultimately i believe new
hampshire is a swing state i believe
candidates should come here to campaign
and even if that means that my party is
not winning all the electoral votes i
think keeping them all together as an
incentive so that new hampshire's votes
are heard in the presidential election
is more important than securing two
electoral college votes so i will be
voting in expedient to legislate is
there any further discussion on this the
motion on the floor which is to itl 1324
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair i will also be voting uh
against house bill 1324 and supporting
the motion for an expedient to legislate
further discussion
seeing none i'm going to have the clerk
call the roll the motion on the floor is
1324 itl
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative mooney
yes
representation
yes representative ward yes
representative bergeron
yes
representative pimento yes
representative hamer yes representative
freitas
yes
representative
the itl on 1324 carries 20 to zero
without objection that will go on the
consent calendar
uh the next
bill to be voted on this morning by the
committee is house bill 1242 relative to
filing deadlines for candidates seeking
election to charter commissions and
relative to the date of such elections
is there a motion representative
bergeron
uh thank you madam chair i would move to
find uh house bill
1153 and expedient to legislate
how about 12 42 ah i would also move to
find house bill 1242 and expedient to
legislate
and i'll speak to that motion
all right well okay
thank you um and is there a second
representative lane seconds it
representative bergeron would you like
to speak to your motion thank you i will
um the reason i asked the committee to
find this inexpedient to legislate
during our
public hearing on the matter is that
senate bill 423 addresses addresses the
same subject matter it was sponsored it
was submitted at the request of the
manchester city clerk and it's the
manchester delegation that's uh behind
senate bill 423 so uh this is redundant
let's put it out of the way and uh we'll
deal with 423 in this subject matter
when it comes back to us
if it comes back to us thank you further
discussion the motion on the floor is
itl1242
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative mooney yes represent
yes
yes represent
representative alexander yes
representative page yes representative
ward yes
representative bergeron
yes
representative pimentel
representative hamer yes representative
lane yes
representative freitas yes
yes
the motion carries 20 to zero without
objection that will go on the consent
calendar the next
bill to be voted on this afternoon by
committee is eleven fifty three this is
relative to absentee ballot requests is
there a motion representative tarosian
thank you madam chair
i make a motion
to find
house bill 1153 ought to pass
discussion on the motion representative
representative alexander thank you madam
chair um i'm going to vote oh do you
want to go first he was he never he
never speaks up so i i went to um
well
i'm very confused
i would just like to note that i
originally was opposed to this bill but
hearing public testimony on how there
are absolute ballots being mailed to
people that aren't registered to vote
is really concerning to me um it's it's
happening so i think this will close a
loophole and clarify this in state law
so i'm voting ot
representative teresian thank you
so
thank you representative for
covering one of the points that i had
we did hear in testimony that this is
this is a practice that happens so if we
heard that from one person i have no
doubt it probably happens in other
places
this is common sense legislation
and
the fact of the matter is i can't think
of any good reason why to send an
official absentee ballot to somebody
that's not a registered voter
in the state
and all this bill does is it closes that
loophole and requires
the individual that requests the
absentee ballot to be a registered voter
and
prior to getting the ballot now i know
some will argue well let's
you you need to get registered to vote
then and that's that's true you do and
you and you can and um let's see we have
a town election coming up in march so
that's plenty of time to go get
registered and the next state election
won't be to what september so
um
there's plenty of time for people to go
out and do that and
if for some reason you missed before you
pulled an absentee ballot you could
still go down and
do a same-day
registration this this bill in no way
prevents that so i ask you to
come with me and
support the otp motion on 1153 thank you
any further discussion representative
bergeron thank you madam chair
i'm going to vote against the motion to
ought to pass
and i i do recall the discussion that
some
residents may obtain absentee ballots
without being first registered to vote
but as was mentioned during
testimony this is specific situations
where
individuals are asking to register to
vote absentee perhaps they're you know
away at school maybe they're they've
gone down to florida for the for the
winter
and they're requesting an absentee
ballot at the same time and as was
explained during public testimony what
will then occur is both the application
and the absentee ballot come back
uh sealed in the absentee ballot
envelope and on election day at the
polls
the moderator will open that first the
voter registrar makes a decision as to
whether or not to allow that person to
be added to the checklist as a same-day
election voter registration
and if they're added to the checklist
then the absentee ballot can be counted
now i know there was testimony that
apparently
this process wanted to be eliminated
but you have to consider the amount of
time it takes for mail to go to go back
and forth
i received a a christmas card this year
that was mailed on december 20th that
was delivered on january 20th and that
just came from portland maine
so my point is if you're taking three
four five weeks to get the voter
registration application out and then
have to wait another three four five
weeks for the absentee ballot to be
mailed out and returned you're probably
going to disenfranchise a number of
people and it's a very small number of
people
i would also point out that regardless
what the intent was if you look at the
actual language in house bill 1153 it
doesn't do anything it's just redundant
uh the actual current language says upon
receipt of a properly executed
application for an absentee ballot the
town of city clerk shall ascertain if
the applicant is on the checklist and if
so send the ballot and the new language
says under no circumstance so a town or
city clerk mail an absentee ballot
unless the person has submitted an
application it's the same language that
already appears in the statute so i in
my opinion it's redundant it's
unnecessary and it doesn't even address
the situation which some supporters of
further discussion
representative terezian
thank you madam chair
after hearing that testimony i
guess some people may have a second
thought about
voting by absentee ballot if it's taken
three weeks for the mail to come so
um
you could use that argument either way
but no
i understand it doesn't create a lot of
extra language but it it reinforces the
idea that you should be a registered
voter before
you
get an
official absentee ballot and i did
consult with both the past secretary of
state and the current secretary of state
on this and they both supported the idea
and said that they quite frankly were
surprised nobody else had done this
earlier
representative barry
uh yes so i was actually originally
going to vote against this bill i didn't
think it was necessary
and then the town clerks association
came and
opened my eyes to how necessary it is
the fact that we are sending actual
ballots to people who are not registered
to vote
that is ridiculous
i asked the um i asked the
representative from the town clerk
association he said well we don't just
send them to just anyone and i said well
what if i call if i say hey it's a week
for the election and i call up from
derry and i say hey i'm not registered
to vote are you going to send me a
balance i said yes that is just anyone
so it i want to thank the sponsor i
didn't think this was necessary
it turns out yes we are in fact mailing
actual ballots to people who are not
registered to vote
that is cause for alarm it leaves a a
gaping wide open loophole
that somebody could just request you
know they could do this 30 times and
then those ballots magically arrive on
election day and there's zero
opportunity to verify this person
actually is who they who actually is a
registered actually as a resident of the
state don't want to go back to that has
their primary residence in the state how
about that um
there's no opportunity to verify that
it's a it's it leaves a
a
six-lane highway open for abuse um we
should not be sending actual ballots to
people that are not registered to vote
that's what we're voting on you're
you're voting to stop sending actual
ballots to people who are not registered
to vote that's that's ridiculous
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
yes
no
representative ward no
represent bergeron no
representative
no
representative hamer
representative lane no representative
freitas
representative hamlet no represent your
head
madam chair
yes
okay 11 to 9.
the motion carries 11 to 9 it will be
recommended otp that was house bill 1153
the next bill before us
for vote this afternoon is 11
66 requiring certain voters to declare
a party affiliation
prior to the date of a state primary
election there was also an amendment
that was presented to the committee
during the public hearing is there a
motion
representative sweeney madam chair i
move we find house bill 1166 and
expedient to legislate
is there a second
i second that madam chair thank you
would you like to speak to your motion
representative sweeney yes ver very
briefly i i do want to just say i i
appreciate the scenario
the sponsor is trying to prevent
with this legislation however i think
all too common for both sides of the
aisle
and for anyone organizing candidates for
the ballot you'll have a situation in
which somebody that could regularly go
to local committee meetings be involved
in their local
either republican or democratic party
apparatus
and then they they tell them in march
you know i'm gonna run for state
representative on this upcoming election
and then we get to june and its filing
period is opener coming up and then
they're like oh i've actually been an
unaffiliated voter this entire time i
need to switch my party affiliation
could be a
a true republican a true democrat in the
sense of ideology
and no disagreement there but just had
not taken the step to register at that
party until right before filing for the
election
does not mean that they are not a
full-throated supporter of that party um
it just means that their paperwork was
not filed and putting in this in this
provision to stretch out the the time
they would have to
change their party affiliation before
running for office would be a big burden
on parties on both parties that fill
seats uh sometimes in areas that aren't
necessarily friendly to the parties so
that's why i would suggest everyone
vote for this to be an expedient to
legislate thank you
any further discussion representative
bergeron oh thank you thank you madam
chair
i also will support the motion to find
this an expedient to legislate
and and i can
verify what the previous speaker was
saying regarding people's perception of
how they might be registered to vote
um
in the city clerk's office in nashville
for example it was not at all uncommon
for people to
revert back to an undeclared status
after voting in a primary and not
realize when it comes close to the time
for filing that they never declared
themselves to be a republican or a
democrat even if maybe they voted that
way for 30 or 40 years previously
um i i think the voters are entitled to
some flexibility uh to stay unaffiliated
if they want to and then change to a
declared party if they want to run for
office at a later time and i
can verify that many times
the chairs of city committees would be
walking people into the clerk's office
to verify that they're registered in
that party so that they can run for
office and if it's done prior to the
checklist closing they will declare
themselves a member of the party so that
the party can fill the slate
so i don't i don't think this is a good
idea
any further discussion on the motion the
representative teresa just a quick point
of clarification maybe i mis heard
something i thought i heard the the
last speaker say that you'd have to
declare what party you're um affiliated
with before you register to vote you
have to do that now did i miss something
there
um no if i could clarify it you have to
declare your party before you file for
candidacy file an office for kennedy so
if you're unaffiliated and you want to
run as a republican you need to declare
that you want to be a member of the
republican so you're changing your voter
registration form you're changing it
from unaffiliated status to to
republican status so you can run as a
further discussion on the motion
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the rule
representative mcdonald yes
representative
o'brien yes representative sweeney yes
yes represent
yes representative ferry yes represents
yes representative
yes clerk is yes representative
alexander yes
representative bergeron
yes
representative page yes representative
ward yes
representative pimentel yes
representative hamer yes representative
elaine yes represent freitas yes
representative hamlet yes represent your
head yeah
11 66 we'll go to this to session as
recommended itl vote was 20-0 without
objection it will go on the consent
calendar the next bill before the
committee this afternoon is 1326.
this is relative to permissible campaign
contributions by
uh business organizations
is there a motion
representative alexander thank you madam
chair i move hb 1326 index meeting to
legislate is there a second i second the
motion representative terrorism second
set representative alexander would you
like to speak to your motion
thank you madam chair um this committee
just passed um sweeping campaign finance
reform last year um did a lot of good it
was signed into law just recently um
i believe you know
um campaign contributions is free speech
and um with the dust just settling on
the campaign finance bill passed last
year
i think we should find this nxp into
legislate thank you
representative lane
thank you madam chair what this bill
does it creates a level playing field
for businesses and labor unions as to
how they contribute
to
political either political organizations
or political campaigns
under the bill the committee's
expenditures
and sorry
expenditures and contributions must be
made through a separate fund consisting
of voluntary contributions from
employees officers shareholders or
members of businesses or labor unions
the bill implements the solution
recommended by judge mcauliffe in his
decision on a previous bill
in which
he suggested that there was a broad
restriction against all contributions
and he said that was too broad and that
what needed to be done
was exactly what this bill does is to
make a level playing field for
corporations and labor unions
and that is it
for
further discussion on the bill
the motion on the floor is itl 1326
not seeing any further discussion i'm
going to call for the clerk to call the
role thank you i'm sorry
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
yes
uh representative alexander yes
representative bergeron no
representative page no representative
ward no
representative pimento no
representative hamer no
representative lane no
representative freitas no
yes
the vote on 1326 is 11 to 9 it will be
recommended to session as an expedient
to legislate the next bill before the
committee
for vote this morning this afternoon is
relative to the election day duties of
incumbent election officials who also
appear on the ballot there was a motion
presented
during
uh public hearing is there a motion on
this representative quayley
thank you madam chairman i move that
this bill be found in expedient to
legislate
is there a second
second the motion madam chair
representative teresa in second state
would you like to speak to your motion
thank you madam chairman yes i would
i'm having read the bill and listen to
the testimonies of public hearing uh
i believe this bill attempts to address
the potential for conflict or appearance
of conflict
which can be presented with certain uh
election officials
and and also uh inspectors of uh
election perform election day duties
uh for elections in which they also
appear on the ballot
it proposes to do so by disqualifying
these particular officials from
performing election duties in such an
election
the bill would also prohibit such
officials from remaining inside the
guard rail during the counting of votes
for the offices for which they are
candidates and furthermore
it proposes that the presence of such
officials in the vicinity of the polling
place
would be confined to the
areas designated for electioneering by
the moderator
i have a lot of sympathy for the in
the intent of this bill but
for me it presents a number of
unresolved issues
first of all i'm concerned about the
constitutionality
uh of the bill
uh the bill's proposal uh in part one
that in order to present conflict uh
prevent conflict or perceive conflict uh
the moderator will would be deprived of
his or her constitutionally mandated
authority and duty to govern elections
and quote receive the votes of the
inhabitants unquote
as i'm sure all familiar new hampshire
constitution part 2 article 32.
in addition the proposal
to limit
an official's presence to the designated
electioneering spaces this is in part
three
for me raises uh
significant first amendment concerns the
law is currently constituted
requires the moderator to provide
a space designated for electioneering
but only excludes electioneering from
the 10-foot wide
non-electioneering corridor that
provides access to the polling place for
voters
so to apply a restriction like this only
on certain specific individuals these
seems to me to be an infringement on
also
the bill proposes to
impose these provisions on the moderator
selectmen and supervisors of the
checklist
there are other election officials
required and generally president
election and the rationale for not
imposing these
restrictions on these other uh election
the town clerk the deputy moderator and
assistant moderator and so forth i don't
see the rationale for limiting it only
to the
the
moderator etc
uh and finally during the uh public
hearings uh for me uh
uh well practical concerns were raised
by those giving testimony and also by
some of our committee members
which to me uh
and these concerns uh regarded
the availability of knowledgeable and
willing substitutes for the moderator in
particular and that would apply to these
other officials as well
with some experience as a selectmen in
in a municipal government i i do think
that would be it couldn't sometimes be a
practical impossibility to find someone
to replace the moderator
the bill in excluding town clerks from
their list of uh disqualified
officials who can be disqualified it
seems to imply that town clerks could
fill that position but as we heard in
the testimony
town clerks have a very different uh
training that they undergo
and also i couldn't find anywhere in the
rsas that empowered a town clerk
to govern an election so the question
would become
who then shall govern the election if
the moderator is excluded
thank you
thank you representative quayley does
anybody else wish to speak to the motion
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair i support the motion to find this
bill in expedient to legislate i think
the
previous speaker did an eloquent job of
summarizing all the reasons why the bill
should not be passed
um i i would just note that well i
thought the sponsor gave a very good
reason why the bill was introduced
it sounded to me more like an
electioneering issue and not
an issue where you suddenly throw out
all the election officials who were
working in a polling place throughout
the state because one person
may have misused the authority that was
given to him in his particular polling
place
i would also note that this issue has
been
getting discussed now for almost 50
years
and every session someone comes along
with an idea to tweak it and make it run
a little better uh i think the process
that's in place right now is is a pretty
good one
uh it ensures that the people who are
most experienced uh and who are elected
by their voters to conduct the elections
are allowed to perform those duties at
the polling places and so i will also be
voting uh to find this bill in expedient
to legislate
thank you does anybody else wish to
speak representative terozian thank you
madam chair i too will be voting for the
an expedient to legislate
motion
um
and primarily because of the
constitutional aspect of i didn't see
any way around
this i thought there were many uh
aspects of this bill that
made sense
and
but the the fact that this is a
constitutional
requirement that the moderator conduct
this i didn't see a way to solve that my
hope however is that going forward and i
know it's been 50 years maybe somebody
will
figure a way to to
to solve this because i can tell you i
hear from constituents and others that
when they see a
town that has a town moderated he may be
running into state rep election doesn't
really matter they say how come he gets
to be inside
when
all the rest of people have to be way
out in that corral you know
in some places that's practically a mile
and a half away from where you come into
the building but
i digress um so
the reality is it is a carve out it is
inconsistent and anytime we have
something that's inconsistent that
always bothers me it was the old saying
uh laws for thee but not for me and so
we did hear testimony that the election
hearing laws are
sufficient to
you know
make this this inconsistency okay
um but one could argue and
and i had
have suggested that if if we feel that
strongly about our election laws being
that well
you know being that strong
there's no reason to have to put um
people that are running
when they're an active
candidate on the ballot
a long distance away from where the
voter comes in so we we have a double
standard here and i hope in the future
we find a way to solve that thank you
further discussion on the motion the
motion is itl hb 1359 representative
lane
just because it doesn't happen very
often
i concur with representative teroshian
and his view and i think it's something
that should be solved because
i was shocked to see people who were on
the ballot behind it when i
went in to vote and it is
i think one of an election integrity
issue so thank you
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the role the bill before us is
1359 and the motion is itl
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
yes
yes representative ward yes
representative hamer
yes representative pimentel
representative lane
yes
represent freitas yes represent hamlet
yes represent your head
madam chair
yes
the motion carries 20 to zero without
objection that will go on the consent
calendar the next and last bill for us
to consider an executive session today
is hb 1394. this is relative to the
reporting of certain campaign
contributions
by limited liability companies
is there a motion representative sweeney
madam chair i move we find house bill
1394 and expedient to legislate i would
like to speak to my motion
is there a second
second
representative sweeney thank you madam
chair um
i'll try to be as brief as i can this
bill does have a number of issues that i
think is important when we consider our
votes today
the first part of the bill
would require candidates or political
committees or political advocacy
organizations who donate funds to other
candidates political committees or
political advocacy organizations
to report the amount which they're
already doing but then also itemize the
source of the funds that they are
contributing to another organization
which we already do in a sense we any
candidate political committee political
advocacy organization in new hampshire
that currently raises or spends at least
has to report their campaign finance
expenditures and receipts
to the state of new hampshire uh to
put on an additional requirement that
when they are making direct
contributions to other entities that
they trace back where the funds came
from in particular is it kind of
highlights a misunderstanding of how
campaigns and political organizations
operate and organize their funds
there's no real tracking
that takes part currently at that level
and this would require an almost an
obscene amount of tracking
for campaigns and committees as is
there's also another part of this bill
we had already dealt with uh in 2021 uh
with legislation
tying llcs and the donations that llcs
make to the members of the llcs and when
we discussed and debated that
legislation at the time
there is no state database to the
members of llcs in new hampshire
nor do we have good tracking of members
of llcs not from new hampshire
so we really can't there's nothing to
compare it to to say oh there's you know
x amount of members in this llc uh and
then to then take it and push it against
individual members contribution limits
when it is funds from the llc and not
from the
the member as is in state law
is just untenable with our current
operations and i i think is an affront
to free speech
which is why i would ask you all to vote
and expedite it to legislate thank you
further discussion on the motion
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair
i think sometimes when we're dealing
with transparency and election laws and
campaign receipts and expenditures
we we have to take try and create a
balance
between
freedom of speech if you will
the right to donate campaign funds to a
campaign or to a candidate
along with issues of transparency and
accountability
this bill would not deny someone the
opportunity to make political
contributions through
the shell of an llc or the organization
of a
llc
but what it does require is that
political contributions uh by a limited
liability company be allocated to
members of the llc
that would thereby prevent the llc from
cloaking the identity of donors from
in-state out-of-state even foreign money
sources
state campaign finance statutes do not
discuss define or even mention llcs
currently and this bill is an attempt to
close the leap polling improve
transparency and accountability in our
election laws and and therefore i will
be voting against the motion to find
representative growing
work in construction and real estate
and development
and
llcs are
the preferred
vehicle
for investment in real estate properties
and sometimes a property we're
developing right now will very likely
have six or eight investors
we do hope it will be profitable for the
investors and
we might make political contributions
from that if it was six or eight
investors and you spread out a hundred
dollar contribution or a five hundred
dollar contribution um
it would be manageable i don't think
it's right be manageable but many real
estate llcs will have 50 or 100 or 200
investors if it's a a high level
development project
and
if if that
llc then makes again a 500 or even a 5
000 contribution and has 200 or 400
members
that have
invested in that llc it's a completely
uh
unsustainable um way of of doing that of
making sure that that goes out and again
as it's been testified we don't keep
track of of who all the individuals are
who invest in that so um i i too will
vote in favor of the itl
further discussion
representative lane
the
secretary of state could
when a llc is formed asks for the names
and put it in the database and it's a
simple fix they ask for the
incorporators when a corporation is
formed and they are all listed
as with an llc they could ask that same
question and it will be in the database
so
it's a problem that can be easily fixed
further discussion
seeing none i'm going to ask for a roll
call on the motion which is itl hb 1394.
representative mcdonald yes
senator o'brien yes representative
yes
represent
representative page no representative
ward no
representative pimentel no
representative hamer no
representative lane no representative
freitas no representative hamlet no
represent
madam chair
yes
1394 will be recommended as itl vote is
11-9 that inclu concludes our executive
session today i want to thank everybody
for powering through lunch hour
uh with me on this um thank you very
much for your attention and your
statements on a lot of very important
issues our next meeting will be march
9th
so so enjoy the lovely day what's the
you